today
joe biden was sworn in as president and
kamala harris was sworn in as vice
president
and that's exactly what i expected over
the past several months that
it was going to be a rather uneventful
inauguration and i guess to the extent
that there was 25 000
national guard occupying dc and
demanding people's
papers to prove they had legitimate
business in the area it was relatively
uneventful
and already well actually literally
while it was happening the media was
putting out some of the most
insane propaganda there was one tweet
from one journalist i won't name
who was like as soon as lady gaga began
singing the clouds broke and
sunlight beamed through onto the capitol
building and then someone commented like
god shows us his grace or something and
i'm just like
it's it's okay sure my favorite
right now is jacobin magazine uh drawing
joe biden has jesus with a bunch of
people worshiping him
you show it amazing well what what gets
all of this
and uh uh already quartz has written
a story what happens if joe biden dies
so uh that's happening and we'll just
we'll just talk a bit about what's going
on i think the scary thing out of all of
this is there's a new poll
out from yougov showing that americans
feel
americans are their biggest threat and
we are now seeing from the establishment
media calls
for spy agencies to target
white supremacy and you know what that
means in the context of these woke
outlets
it means like regular americans who
aren't woke
and that's probably where we're gonna
end up going so we'll we'll jump in all
that stuff and joining us today is mr
jack murphy hey everybody good to be
back it is every other wednesday and i'm
back jack murphy live how are you
so uh jack you want to just quick quick
quick uh bio just run down there
yeah sure you can find me on twitter at
jack murphy live i wrote a book democrat
to deplorable you can get
that got to come up with a new one now
though not sure what that's going to be
about
and uh global out deplorable we quit
republicans suck too
right uh you know there's there's a lot
of change happening a lot of transitions
happening but this
is still the same happy to be back tim
thanks for having me
of course luke rudkowski is hanging out
well i got to shoot and squat
today so today was a great day
everything else boom
not so great i also started a new
website today that is called
are you ready for this what is it
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
it's true yeah they're not they're not
political i still like them i'm going to
wear them as well
well i do have one show that's about
censorship and it's like the pyramid
being toppled over and uh it's good i
ordered a gorilla shirt tonight
potentially we got a couple more we got
the tin foil special edition coming soon
we just got to figure out we're gonna
we're gonna launch it yeah
probably gonna you know try and find a a
different company
for the special release that'll be
listed on the site for a limited time
but it's a girl with a tin foil hat so
we got ian hanging out there was a
request to run that uh limited offer
shirt for at least a week because people
get paid on friday so we'll make sure we
give everyone a chance
we'll do thursday to thursday thursday
do it on the 1st and the 15th
i as well as you are uh share a common
ancestor with gorillas
so let's celebrate we do i was thinking
back in my first second i'm like
way back wait how did you know about our
day our father right exactly
he was a gorilla yeah yes your dad my
dad's brother of course we got sour
patch let's press it in the corner liz
yeah prematurely
so man uh you know we talk about
americans
being scared of other americans right
now there's news that in portland
anti-fuzz smashing up the dnc
headquarters
so that's entirely predictable and we're
going to go through all that but before
we get started
i am eternally grateful we have a
sponsor today helping make sure that we
don't go out of business
and our sponsor today is flex pro meals
it is a meal preparation service
in the description below you can click
the link and use the code timcast20 to
get 20
off of your meal prep it's really cool
stuff i'm going to read you a bit about
it
they say flex pro meals uses quality
ingredients
that are not only healthy but
extraordinarily tasty it might have you
questioning whether or not these meals
are even healthy but do not worry
flex pro meals will help you easily get
in shape with flex pro meals you get
high quality meals delivered fast to
your doorstep
this helps save a ton of time with a
busy schedule
so again go to flex pro meals links in
the description below timcast20 and
i'll be completely honest i think meal
prep is fantastic so if you're someone
who's trying to eat right
and you don't necessarily know how to do
it because a lot of people don't you
know you might go to
fast food restaurant and you think
you're getting a meal with a salad but
they put sugar in the salad what are
they doing
you can go to flex pro meals and you can
pick out they got like garlic chicken
alfredo they got sesame chicken
and then just right ready to go boom
you're good you're healthy one thing i
like about them too is they maintain
portions for you right
yes dude americans eat so do you ever go
to a diner we went to a diner and we
ordered i ordered like the appetizer
sampler
with like four people and i'm like dude
this is like 5 000 calories
that's crazy and then i ordered fish and
chips and it was just like i can't eat
this
i don't understand why they do that it's
like wasting money in food you know
that's what people have come to expect
maybe
well you know what man we gotta we gotta
chill so uh get your
meal prep done for you with
flexpromise.com thanks so much for the
sponsorship guys i really do really do
mean
and don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member to help support the show
directly
in the event that we get nuked in the
great purge because
i think it's coming we really need to
build up that defensive barrier and
that's what we need your help for so
teamcast.com
and if you want to get your exclusive i
am a gorilla t-shirt
go to timcast.com click the shop button
and you in fact
can get your own and then we're gonna
have an exclusive tinfoil hat version
coming soon
but let's uh let's jump into the first
story and we'll talk about joe biden
being president
and this glorious image from jacobin
magazine
now i'll tell you what i find
particularly fascinating about this is
jacobin is like socialist
like their their dsa many are like
communism
it's they get their name from the french
revolution and they've
put a cover out and it's joe biden as
jesus with the sun
behind his head literally imagery of
jesus and there are people below him
like
looking up and cheering and worshiping
him
and there's angels filming and
interviewing him what
are these people thinking this smacks of
the french revolution the
this was uh what's his name's party um
yeah ross pierre's party was the
jacobins correct me if i'm wrong here
but they
he actually became they wanted to get
rid of christianity and he
portrayed himself as a deity and came
down from the mountain and they wanted
to create he wanted to create a new
religion around himself and this is like
a
i don't know if they don't know that or
if this is a sick joke or
or if they really are like maybe that's
why they're doing it
i mean politicians are not supposed to
be worshiped they are servants they're
supposed to be
serving the people and i don't care if
it's joe biden q anon donald trump stop
with this
obsession with putting people above
yourself and putting all their
responsibilities in all your failures
and all your hopes into one person
and and take some gosh darn personal
responsibility for yourself
we're supposed to be saying too early
we're supposed to be doing this we're
supposed to be senior chairs going
joseph joseph come here clean up this
mess we've hired you to take care of
these problems
instead they create the problems and
they do whatever they want
they enrich themselves they're not
solving the problems i think we were
talking about this before
the difference between a statesman and
what we currently have with crony
politicians
someone who actually gets an off who
gets elected and says i'm going to go in
and focus on solving these problems for
you
and then what we have like one or two
who actually do but when you have
a media ecosystem that is acting like
joe biden
is literally jesus then i don't see how
we we actually
solve problems just to clarify my point
joe biden could do really horrible
things and they don't care
but it's funny because they say the same
thing about you know donald trump i'm
kind of at a place where it's like just
let them have their fun
but i don't know what were you going to
say jack i was just going to say how are
you going to criticize
jesus yeah come on man setting him up to
be untouchable and then i'm also
reminded and i'm about ready to do this
thing i hate where i say what about
i'm also reminded about uh this summer
uh when they were tearing down statues
of abraham lincoln
where lincoln's standing there and he's
got his hand out and there's a slave
on his knees breaking out of his change
and standing up a joy like rapture's
face up to
up to abraham lincoln this this cover
with biden as jesus hovering above a
black family in
masks looking up at him like he's got
that is no different
well it is the i mean i guess
technically the
the statue of abraham lincoln was paid
for and built
like organized by former slaves who were
saying thank you to
to lincoln now the leftist today got
that statue removed they actually
approved it was in boston they i can't
believe it they took it
there's one in dc they're trying to take
down the same same statue they taking it
down because they're like it shows that
black people were at one point slaves
and so they want to erase that they
don't want that idea to exist
so they got rid of it it worked this is
people worshipping
jesus biden who hasn't done anything
what does he what did he do he was
defeated right up against the wall
defeated the devil there you go the evil
trump
he may have uh performed what would they
call it sexual aggressive acts against
tara reid
in the and children and in his workplace
you know
it's it's really hard because i feel
like the things they
threw at trump were preemptive defensive
techniques
like you better accuse trump of it
before it comes at us yes
because the democrats are swimming in
the corruption and the swamp
and so they're like let's make sure
everybody thinks trump is corrupt for
like
the emoluments clause for instance joe
biden sending his kid to china on air
force two
a bit different it's like we live in the
empire from star wars and it's like
people just want to just chill out and
just accept it you just want to be a
citizen
man you just want to reap the benefits
of the empire
controlling all these planets and
countries or whatever
well so this is the thing i was
mentioning this earlier i tweeted
i often wondered what pro-empire
propaganda would look like in the star
wars universe
and it's because we have the entirety of
dc locked down by the national guard
many of whom have no idea why they're
there
in order to get in you've got to show
your papers proving you have legitimate
business
why because the storming of the capital
i don't think we need 25
000 troops locking down the entire
capital no it's
as adam townsend said on twitter it's
about imprinting history on people's
brains
so that in 20 30 40 50 years they just
looked back and like
oh things must have been terrible they
had to have 25 000 troops in the capital
no one will no one remember the nuance
i've lived in dc for 30 years i've been
through a number of inaugurations i have
never
once heard of incoming traffic shut down
over the bridges
coming into the city the area that they
blocked off it's like i
it's like 20 times the size of anything
that had ever been blocked off before it
was just
mind-boggling troops marching
troops marching down the streets there's
a famous meme going around right now
with all the soldiers
uh and and the motorcade going through
and it says we defeated fascism
and uh and again those images are
extremely visceral for a reason
and we have to ask ourselves why did we
do this why did we
locked down the capital of the united
states
under a military occupation when there
was no protest
i'm hearing a lot of reports of no
protesters at all being seen anywhere
near
even the vicinity of washington dc
protesting uh biden it's the opposite
every single like trump forum was like
don't go don't go to dc
people were saying like don't do it
don't go but on the mainstream media we
heard non-stop
24 7 breaking news coverage of threat
assessments it's going to get bad it's
going to get ugly people
there's it's going to get bloody and
dangerous and and what happened
it was such a winning move though
because now all they can say is like
there was a threat we responded to the
threat and we prevented it from
happening
oh yeah because we put the troops there
yeah it's a winning move no matter what
think about the media narrative right
now and how say wikipedia works
they just take whatever op ed and i'm
not saying
i'm i'm serious they take op-eds
and someone will say there was an
insurrection it's all about framing
so i'm sure if you if you now look at
what the historians are writing they're
going to say there was an attempted
insurrection by white supremacist
terrorists
and then in 50 years that's what they
want everyone you know history is
written by the victors
they want everyone to look back at this
day and say trump's army of white
supremacists
stormed the capital you know planning to
kill and kidnap
members and so the troops were deployed
to protect the city to prevent another
insurrection it was a trying time
and they did it and they successfully
were able to fight it back
and it's only going to get worse from
here as we're seeing very
extreme language from individuals like
john brennan
the former cia director that literally
lied under oath about so many different
things whether spying or the steele
dossier
he came out today on the mainstream
media and he said the biden
intelligence organizations are moving in
quote laser-like fashion
to uncover the trump insurgent
insurgency
and the people who harbored it including
religious extremists
authoritarians fascists biggest
nativists and even libertarians this was
this was libertarian he said yes john
brennan
said that biden's intelligence agencies
are moving in
laser-like fashion against libertarians
that's a political party yeah
yes yes that's why i just i tweeted the
video out because i couldn't believe it
because i saw people talking about it
but but we have the former cia director
you know the epitome of the deep state
talking about biden going after
libertarians now because of everything
that happened
the nativist thing was particularly
interesting yes they're making it now
that if you oppose immigration in any
way you're a nist of some sort
and they're making nativists like racist
so i was listening i i
didn't do a 1 pm segment today because i
was watching i had to watch the
inauguration i
you know and it was happening at the
same time i normally you know produce
and record and i remember when joe biden
mentioned you know rejecting the hate of
nativists
and i was like it's a really interesting
choice of words now people who are like
you're native to the country you get
preferential treatment is wrong it's an
ist and they're going to use it like
racist i would uh so already
wait native to the country means
american
yes right right so if you're an american
yes
and believe that that's important and a
good thing youtube already made the rule
a year ago
that if you disparage non-citizens for
being not citizens you will be banned
but most importantly he went on and he
said all of these things
nativists libertarians are a threat to
democracy and are insidious those are
his
exact inflammatory words that are
extremely reckless
extremely dangerous but also most
importantly extremely untrue
when we talk about libertarians what are
they guilty of not liking the government
being unsuccessful in politics having
cruddy
candidates uh having some ideas about
you know individual sovereignty and
liberty
what are they guilty of what do they do
how do you lump a libertarian in with a
fascist
yeah uh when when everything
again this is another thing we need to
realize here this whole democratic party
was
built as a large hammer hitting nails
so if you're a hammer everything's going
to start looking like nails for you
because that's your single duty
that's the main kind of apparatus that's
how the democratic party
gained power in 2020 let's be honest
here they took down a lot of people and
that's how they were able to
step on them and get a step above
everybody else and
they know that works they know that this
is going to be implemented even more
before this and it doesn't take a genius
to see that the writing is on the wall
that we're going to see an expansion of
this moving forward yeah i think it's
important to point out too that this
process
started in the 60s when the democrats
made a very conscious decision to make
themselves the party of everybody but
the white guy
and to go against the white guys in the
in the late 60s 1968 if you want to
learn more about this
check out matt stoller's book goliath
there's a whole big detailed section
about
the deliberate course of action that the
democrats took and so
the the nail is white dudes
and the hammer is what now the state and
all the non-white dudes behind them the
state
and the cia the fbi and that's why when
when alex was here he said
i am a gorilla but love yourself
we can all because the idea of that book
was you know discussion we were having
was
that the the establishment wants you to
live in the wilderness they want you to
live
you know like we used to hundreds of
years ago and that was a general concept
you know to be completely honest i think
people would do well to get out into the
wild i was gonna say that sounds like
right
good but the idea was like destroying
modern civilization and technology
because we're destructive
it reminds me of the matrix when agent
smith is like you know
humans are not animals they're viruses
you know i'm not gonna do the whole
speech
but that's basically what he says
because animals he say he says
build a natural equilibrium with their
environment whereas humans just
reproduce move around and destroy and
like a virus
that's the same idea from you know my
understanding from that book and so the
idea is to get humans back into
eco state you know uh stability with the
natural environment
and then that requires you know the
average person to give up this this way
of life
so now you i think what we're seeing
especially with the great reset
especially with
the you know the democratic politicians
who have defied their own lockdown
orders
the idea is if the rich people are to
maintain their lifestyles
everyone else has to sacrifice with them
so that's what they want that's where
we're headed
all the climate change stuff you know
whatever that's where we'll go
yeah i read ishmael am i supposed to
talk about that right now
it was like it was like 12 years ago
ishmael is the book where the gorilla
comes from these the gorillas called
ishmael this is
and in the book they talk about takers
and leavers humans have kind of
divided into these tribes of types of
people one is the takers and that
there's so many takers right now
in the world that and the levers we've
basically desecrated i think they refer
to like the native americans as leavers
in a lot of ways
protecting the land you know allowing
although they were massacring buffalo
and each other and eating each other i
mean it was pretty vicious
yeah but the idea is to to become
leavers and not and to give up our
taking ways and and that i think has a
lot of merit
that's the difference between being a
producer and a consumer i think yeah
yeah
leave mo leave the world a better place
than how you found it the problem is
i don't trust the people who are pushing
this kind of garbage and
now we're getting it tenfold with joe
biden he's going in you know paris
climate agreement that kind of stuff
yeah so for critical race theory even if
you do think it's a good idea you can
really look a scan to the people who are
pushing it
people like i don't know bill gates or
whoever george
bill gates pushing it while at the same
time pic acquiring
every last piece of available farmland
in america
now he's the largest farm owner in all
of the united states i doubt that wow
mr monsanto the man who like bankrolled
pretty much monsanto with all the stock
purchases
is now in control of the united states
food supply in many ways but now
if you had all that money and you knew
that we were going to print up trillions
of dollars
what is what is the best thing to buy in
that case
beachfront property because of course
there's climate change and
we have to worry about the rising ocean
types as bill gates literally bought
oceanfront property
so that tells you everything that we
need to know indeed but raleigh
and farmland over time have tracked
money supply
pretty pretty closely yeah so that's a
good place to be he must think that
there's a lot of inflation coming oh
yeah
yeah yeah i wonder why so here was the
uh
here was here's the the joke i i
mentioned so we have this from uh on
twitter from
bellagis is that a pronounce his name oh
blasi it says he tweeted up and to the
right and it's a picture of the m1 money
stock
skyrocketing yep and y'all know how does
that mean money printer gober
yep you're ready it's going for sure no
the money is going
i moved away from the mic cause i don't
want to blow your eardrums
yeah it's just that's the sound i'm
making it's just you look at the money
m1 money stock and it's just
i'm imagining a man screaming at the top
of his lungs
so yeah yeah i don't i don't know though
people don't have money
right so some people have mentioned
maybe there wasn't enough money in in
circulation and one of the issues is if
people aren't working at all because of
the covet lockdown
and they're desperate for any amount of
money then we might actually see
deflation
the wealth will go well i will
concentrate into the hands of the ultra
rich the politicians the elites
and they'll hoard it then by holding on
to it and strangling out
the working people a normal person who's
like i need 15 bucks an hour
might finally just break and say give me
ten i don't care i have nothing
and then you can get the same amount of
labor from that person for cheaper
because there's no money for them
not if the democrats get their way you
won't be allowed to hire anybody for
less than 15
an hour all across the country no no but
but think about it what they're doing is
money printing
and that at the same time yeah is
tricking people into thinking they're
getting more when they're not
correct yeah so with the mass printing
of money yep
the people then getting uh saying oh
i'll get 15 bucks an hour
they're gonna have the same buying power
their lives will not improve
if they if they even can get a job even
if they're valued at 10 or 12
an hour in terms of their utility well
this is the thing the job question is
really really big because
when we have the lower skilled jobs
being taken by immigrants when we have
the higher paid jobs being taken because
of these visas that are going to be
reintroduced what jobs are left
none of them and you would think you
know failing wages huge health care
costs and the collapse
collapsing economy would be something
worth noting and talking about
but sadly this is something that hasn't
been mentioned and talked about
i mean we're we're talking about it but
not many people are which is even more
scary you know what's really crazy about
this too take a look we'll pull back up
the m1 money stock
the real expansion of the money supply
it started
in after the financial crisis so when
you look at this major
sharp uptick look at the angle from 2008
until 2020 before the major spike
and it was still rapidly increasing
right
so i don't know exactly what we can
expect some people have said
my supply doesn't track perfectly with
how the economy functions or anything
like that
but i think you print all this money
then you get joe biden coming out saying
everyone gets a raise at 15
an hour and then there's enough money in
circulation to balance out that wage
increase
while not giving anyone an increase in
buying power yeah the argument is that
you would increase
the gdp to debt ratio which is what
happened after world war ii they printed
a ton of money at world war ii and then
instead of paying back the debt they
just grew the gdp the gross domestic
product
so rapidly that the debt became
negligible and they never ended up
paying it back but that's a that's a
healthy use of debt if you can borrow
money to grow your business your
enterprise or whatever in such a way
that it dwarfs the size of the debt
that's a healthy
that's actually a healthy way and i've
seen economists make the argument that's
what's going to happen now but it
doesn't seem like our gdp is going to be
able to expand that quickly and that we
even have we don't have the industry
that we had in 1945 how would all the
lockdowns in all the factories in china
how and asset price inflation but that's
that's why there are concerns about
deflation
if people don't work they don't have
money period
and they'll do anything and they'll get
desperate and you can be like
whereas a normal person might be a
middle manager at a paper company or a
cracker factory
and they make you know 65 000 a year you
take away that job
their their savings is drying up and
then you come to and say i'll give you a
buck to shine my shoe they'll be like
thank you sir
and that's how you knock people well
everything is becoming more and more
digital so the likelihood of that
happening
um is is less in my opinion but also on
the other hand we
are going through a national coin
shortage yeah so
and then there is a huge kind of larger
kind of psychological
push to make you know regular fiat notes
something dirty something that transmits
diseases something that we should stay
away from
there's this push has been kind of
happening for a while it's kind of been
put in overdrive with kovid
so there's there's a big big push to
promote a cashless society
which is another big agenda which could
manipulate control people
very effectively and that's what i've
been saying about bitcoin for a long
time
i i that's why i'm surprised i didn't
buy bitcoin sooner because even when
bitcoin was at like 50 bucks
i was telling people that it was the
perfect currency for the international
elites
who want to be able to track every
exchange of currency around the world
it's a better technology it's trackable
and
you can you can secretly seize control
very very easily
it's called the 51 attack and of course
the united states has enough money to do
it
i should have bought right then because
that's like kind of obvious
that there was there was so much in the
conspiracy world about a one world
currency
i remember back in like the 2000s people
were talking about the amero do you
remember that luke
yes north america i actually talked to
the mexican president about that and
it was vicente fox and he was openly
pushing for that
now he's and they interviewed him after
he was president now he's pushing for
drug legalization
very interesting guy but vicente fox was
like was like yes we need a north
american union
we need one currency between canada
mexico and the united states of course a
lot of the democrats promoted
this larger idea because they also
promoted the trans-pacific partnership
they also promoted nafta
all of these larger deals which of
course help out multinational
corporations and
screw over the blue collar worker so
imagine imagine if
if mexico was tied in with the united
states and canada economically what kind
of larger exploitation would actually
happen
well by the big multinational powers
they like being able to hire people in
jurisdictions they don't have human
rights laws
i remember when uh i first visited
canada and i was talking to a friend of
mine
i think it's like 14 16 years ago or so
it wasn't like the wasn't it like for
every one us dollar got seven canadian
like the exchange rate was pretty
wild and so i was talking to a friend of
mine who said that they loved it
because americans would jump the border
and then go party and just spend money
like crazy and it was great they could
pay their rent very easily
it was harder to buy international
products but their base goods their food
their shelter was very easily covered by
americans who would come and spend
then when everything started to
normalize that stopped happening
and it became harder for a lot of people
in the service industry to make good
money
because they didn't have the wealthy
americans coming and spending all the
cash and
this was part of a conversation about
economic normalization i was having with
a friend
so when it comes to and we've seen
things like this uh in europe
when it comes to trying to make
everybody on the same standard
it's very very difficult to do if it's
done with a finger snap government
proposal and they do it overnight
but that's why bitcoin and
cryptocurrency is so interesting with
this this this constant escalation of
the currency that's driving up and up
and up
it's getting everyone to be like i want
to do it it's building confidence in it
as a store of value
so people are buying in they're buying
other crypto and it is creating a
one world cashless society we're on that
path
through cryptocurrency is that a good
thing um it could be used either way
um we've seen a lot of foreign
governments get into the bitcoin game
whether it's china
or even more recently pakistan deciding
that they're going to be officially
mining
with uh pakistani government money so
it could go in a way where it's used as
the kind of one world currency that's a
cashless grid
total control lack of privacy coin
initiative or it could be used on the
other hand to promote privacy with
privacy coins like monero that are out
there zcash
that do try to hide transactions so
people could still keep their privacy
which i think is important it's a
double-edged sword it's just like the
internet and it all depends on the user
base
what do you do with it what do you
incentivize if you incentivize
you know corporatist globalist coins
that work with the big banks well
obviously those will prosper
if you incentivize privacy coins that
prioritize
your liberty and freedom well of course
those will prosper so right now we're in
the deciding phase of this larger
cryptocurrency revolution
that's unfolding right now that is still
yet to be determined if it's going to be
really good
or really bad for personal freedom look
at social media networks
it was really good for a while and then
started to get really really bad
and then the government realized or i
should say political establishment
realized
oh no we've lost control by giving the
plebs the the ability to communicate
with each other quick take it back
yeah but we wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for that little opening there was
a little opening
right and and that opening has allowed
me to have a job
a independent media organization allowed
you to have a job
allowed other people to have a voice i
don't know uh jack about your personal
kind of history but
there was a moment where everything was
it was like the wild west it was amazing
it was beautiful
anything you saw was organic it was real
it was it was
it was genuine it wasn't corporate it
wasn't fake it wasn't
talking points it isn't regurgitation of
disney disney bull crap
shoved in your face and it gave rise to
me
you and alex jones and you jack
do you think you really think that the
wild west era is over
in terms of how do we engage with this
universal connectivity it's it's closing
in very severely especially with
controlled algorithms especially with
demonetizations especially with the
larger programming that's be
that's going behind a lot of these
social media companies that are trying
to
shape people's mind and to program them
into a way that benefits
their them and their elites if anything
that i've gotten from reading belagi
and talking to people about ethereum and
whatever else is that we're just in the
opening stages of this internet thing
and that as soon as we crack the
decentralization issue
we'll be back into yeah complete
wildlife i agree with maybe but that's a
major issue
i i don't know how to technical how do
we how do we push decentralization to a
point where
not everyone is dependent on google when
they control all the information
highways when they control the major
infrastructure of the internet it's nice
google though it's that they all work in
concert yeah but look at parlor
amazon says okay we'll ban you google
says we'll take you out of the app store
parlor can't operate without a
substantial uh
web hosting web services because of how
much data is processed by people posting
and downloading at the same time i think
someone posted an image where parlor
said it was like 300 gigabits a second
for like right and so i mean
that's that's huge yeah who's gonna be
able to provide that other than
amazon he's gonna have to try and find
some data centers and things like that
makes it tough
but i'll just say right now man the wild
west has been over for a long time the
wild west ended well before this the
wild west
ended in what like the end of the 2000s
when political establish
like political elites and the political
establishment started to realize the
power what they could get from it
you look back to the era of hamster
dance
simultaneously existing with goatsee and
people sending you these things like
i shouldn't say don't look up goatsy by
the way and don't do that right
and there are a bunch of crazy things
there was a period
of just anything goes napster
kazaa limewire downloading anything
those days are gone i mean you still
have the pirate bay i believe they're
still they're operating
but that was the wild west then the
government came in
and it started to solidify everything
and it became more like
decentralized cities and villages under
the strict rule of like the sheriff
today the internet is basically a big
city you've got low mom and pop shops
that pop up sometimes
and the city you know health inspector
shows up to shut you
down when you say naughty words yeah i
have faith in human
ingenuity and i believe that we will
there will be a new
wild west era in this world of
connectivity that we're talking about
there will
i hope so bittrex though you were
mentioning the privacy coins
monero z cash and dash particularly um
bitrex stopped servicing them at the
beginning of january they announced it
for american customers and they won't
reveal why they stopped servicing them
but that is
highly uh national security letters yeah
who knows what's going on government
comments
there's no way yeah there's there's a
there's it's very difficult to track
you know users and and their money flow
so a lot of americans have been
uh told that they can't have those coins
they can't use them
uh total speculation and just wild ass
question
what's stopping the federal government
from just buying up all the bitcoin
nothing and that's why i just said a 51
attack
is is very very easy all you have to do
to control the network is own
51 of the nodes and that can be easily
accomplished by a nation state
especially the united states
what's the total market cap right now
bitcoin is of all crypto is like 900
billion or something
yeah i'll give you the exact number we
just cranked out four trillion dollars
if the u.s wanted to or the federal
reserve wanted to
they would just spend the print the fiat
buy up as much as possible and then not
tell anyone
they would make a lot of uh
anti-government libertarians very rich
in the process yeah right and they would
and they would and they don't care
they want listen all of these
anti-government libertarian types the
ant caps the anarchists and the
conspiracy theorists were screaming
get bitcoin you got to stop it and they
bought into a totally
public infrastructure where you can
track every transaction yeah
and people need to realize that because
a lot of people don't even understand
that basic fact
everything you do with bitcoin there's a
public ledger there's public
transactions that anyone and everyone
could see all the money coming in and
all the money coming out people fail to
realize that but also very interesting
crypto's the wrong word yeah right it
makes it sound secret well that's just
bitcoin but there are
you know other kind of smaller coins out
there that do focus on privacy and mesh
networks and all these other stuff but
very interestingly
when the us government took down the
silk road
uh when they took down ross ulbricht
they had a huge
amount of bitcoin that they seized from
that personal website and then they
started auctioning it off they started
selling it to the general public back to
them
so um yeah yeah you're shaking your head
there like by the way they just put this
so yeah the fbi i think it was an fbi
agent responsible
for the ross obrecht case was was
found to to actually confiscate and
steal and personally use a lot of the
bitcoin
which put the trial in question because
it proved that the officers involved
weren't doing the right thing so if they
weren't doing the right thing with that
ross ulbricht and his and his mom and
his legal team were arguing saying well
maybe we should throw the case out
because there's clear government
misdoing in this case
we got it we got it this is the perfect
segue and now donald trump did not
pardon
anybody worth part okay hold on let me
slow down i think some people got
pardoned to
i'm cool with there are people who like
you know they were like regular people
who committed crimes
50 years ago or like 30 years ago served
20 years
and they had like no opportunity for
parole until trump pardons or commutes
their sentences
there was uh uh lil wayne i'm actually
totally fine with that pardon
what was it he had like a drug charge
and a gunshot gun or a gun charged
uncharged did he have a drug charge
yeah yeah yeah right yeah he was fun
with a gun i don't i
i think that's that's fine but he
pardoned steve bannon over the build the
wall thing but not
the veteran the the triple amputee
veteran who was also a part of that
he pardoned this the corrupt mayor of
detroit
he didn't pardon ross albrecht or
snowden or reality winner or assange
or joe exotic he didn't even pardon joe
exotic yeah come on
joe exotic said he was too gay and too
innocent to get a pardon from trump
but he actually did as that's that's
what he said there
this was a chance for him to to go out
with some sort of
i don't know pride isn't the right word
just integrity integrity doing the right
thing
yeah doing the right thing and and and
he did no look
look were there probably threats made to
him if he did this then the senate might
you know confirm the impeachment or
whatever i don't even know
maybe they said that if you don't do
then we won't come after you later
either way dude
you know it was an opportunity that was
missed and and it will leave a salty
salt
it's not an opportunity that was missed
it's a slap in the face to anyone paying
any attention
steve bannon steve bannon was literally
accused of stealing money from trump
supporters he gets a pardon
he gets accused no what happened with
steve bannon was that
people who donated to build the wall to
build the wall fund were told
that i believe the guy's name was
kolfage would not receive a salary
later on they indirectly were paying him
money through i think bannon
and that was fraud we still don't know
that but we still don't know exactly
what happened i said he was accused
that's that's what happened there still
was no court proceeding yet
it's going to happen we're going to find
out more the issue about what happened
well i'll ask you jack do you think
any trump supporter who donated money to
build the wall cares that cole phage was
getting a salary
no none no i i agree and so him so
bannon getting the pardon i say yeah
sure fine
but not the other dudes involved yeah
but trump supporters were happy to give
them money i think it's ridiculous they
went after him for this i still think
there's more to the case that we're
going to find out we don't know it yet
because the court proceeding hasn't
happened but look at the other people
kodak black
i mean he's a rapper that literally made
a music video
depicting trump supporters as the clan
and personally choking out a trump
supporter with a make america great
again hat
so he he gets a pardon israeli spies
that were involved in real espionage
get a pardon mercenaries accused of war
crimes
get a pardon i mean are you kidding me
and then we have assange snowden
all bricked all of them just shunned
ignored and essentially what donald
trump did is he put the final nails in
the coffin for julian assange he is
never going to get out
he might as well just of executed him it
was donald trump who said in the
beginning
i love wikileaks then when he became
president he got pressed on it he said
oh i don't know who julian assange is
and now
we're getting information that it was
him and his administration that led to
julian assange's arrest
he's he knowingly according to some
sources was getting pushed by many
individuals to pardon assange this was
widely popular amongst his base and now
he just totally ignored him and julian
assange will rot
in jail for the rest of his life listen
he he essentially signed
the execution order on him which is
absolutely disgusting and unforgivable
the q people are freaking out right now
because
you know trump left the white house it's
over and
uh if there was a conspiracy that i'd be
willing to believe at this point
is that trump was deep state trump's a
scumbag and he's a liar
if listen listen i don't really think
trump was part of the establishment
elites but i certainly think they scared
him enough to where he didn't
he would he wouldn't he went up out of
line okay i would careful with him you
know you know you know i think it was
i think once trump realized he lost when
he saw what was going on
and they went to him they probably told
him they will come after you
if you if you free us on she was
probably like okay what can i do and
they said
rappers some friends just you know hook
your buddies up and then go away and
we'll leave you alone they won't leave
him alone they don't want him to run
over again
i think they're gonna they're gonna go
after him and try to crucify the guy and
he probably thought as long as he played
it safe they'd leave him alone but
they won't he must be extremely stupid
if you think that's going to happen
because he got
played over that two thousand dollars by
mitch mcconnell
like like just a little child smacked
around and and totally lied to about
that situation so what made him think
that mitch mcconnell was going to tell
him the truth after just screwing him
about the major promise of two thousand
dollars it would be absolutely naive
and idiotic of him to do that but it's
not only the pardons that were pathetic
also his declassifications were utterly
useless
he succumbed to every classification
request by the fbi
his last order was resending an order
allowing politicians to become lobbyists
quicker are you kidding me legacy
he surrendered so that's what it is
trump got on his knee to the deep state
to biden
and said spare me and let me live i'm
sorry
and they're not going to of course
they're not i don't know i don't know
about that
the precedent of prosecuting a former
president no i just i'm saying that they
they we don't do that right
oh they're going to love to these these
if they do that though but if that was
then that
opens the gates for that to happen i
don't know but look at the state level
zealous far left prosecutors have
already been ramping this up yes
it's not safe you have nancy pelosi and
hillary clinton literally talking about
crazy conspiracy theories about vladimir
putin being on the phone with donald
trump during the capital siege
there's going to be a major overhaul of
people going after donald trump and his
supporters which he never stood up for
if and if if he did what you said he did
to save his own but it's extremely
selfish and it's not going to work and
it's extremely idiotic in my opinion
sorry go ahead no
i was interrupting you kind sir uh no
then
they're going to go after the people yes
and the people more than they're going
to go after him
they're going to go after anybody that
has any whiff
of any dissident of anything having to
do with being
maga or even just white or even just
being a dude
it's all coming they can't allow trump
to happen again
they've been saying it since he got
elected they're saying it now they've
been calling for truth and
reconciliation they've been calling for
deprogramming
and the media will lie about it donald
trump bent the knee
and and begged to be spared and then
walked out doing very little in fact
making things worse it was
yeah he
order that said that for five years
after someone serves in i don't know
what it is a political office they can't
be a lobbyist who signed that executive
order do you guys trump
he signed the executive order and then
he signed it that's what makes it
terrible
before he leaves so that he and his
friends can become lobbyists
in the next five years he surrendered to
the crony establishment
on the last day he said i won't do
anything the people have requested
tucker carlson went on tv and said
pardon julian assange
veritas put out the in put out the video
showing that julian assange
informed the deep state i'm sorry the
state department
freudian slip it wasn't it's true he
that
veritas part of this video where julian
assange called the state department
saying
someone is going to leak these documents
we don't have control over this
we want to let you know what's happening
proving that there was never an intent
from from wikileaks to publish
unredacted information to get people
hurt it wasn't them it was somebody else
you had conservatives and trump
supporters stepping up begging
begging trump do this one thing and what
did trump do
the corrupt former mayor of detroit the
rapper you mentioned to strangle a trump
supporter on video
he rescinded his own executive order to
allow the swamp to walk
right back in yep israeli spies accused
of actual espionage and actually dealing
with
legal ramifications from it i mean and
then what is uh assange accused of
espionage right he's not even an
american citizen that's the biggest
take here and if the united states is
able to get away with
shutting down a man throwing him in jail
driving him crazy
and essentially locking him up for the
rest of his life that is an extremely
dangerous president set that of course
is going to be used and abused
by the next president by the next person
in charge that of course now has this
huge power
to take anyone in the world for
publishing information that they don't
like
and saying that's it you're going to the
rest of your life we're throwing the key
away and not even looking back
you've got to watch v for vendetta it's
just such a good movie
i've been on the show what 10 12 times
now every single time we talk about it
and i still haven't seen it i'm gonna
watch listen listen
next there's the scene where the
chancellor says i want them to know why
they need us
and then more importantly when v storms
the broadcast
center and displays the message saying
there's something terribly wrong with
this country if you
see what i see if you feel as i feel
meet me in front of the old bailey on
the 5th of november in one year
and they said he's a terrorist right you
see what they do
they want to make sure you're the
boogeyman here's the fascinating thing
to all these lefties who called
themselves the resistance
you were never the resistance you were
the the cronies you were the the the
lackeys of the establishment elites
who are trying to stop trump who was
kicking the door in
and the easiest way to understand that
is since when is the resistance
supported by every major multinational
corporation and the establishment
political party now what's going to
happen is
you want to know the real resistances
the people that are
that are libertarians like like uh luke
mentioned
the people who believe in individual
freedoms who believe in the declaration
of independence the constitution
who will now be called nativist and
white supremacists
and we have the story from the daily
beast from just a couple days ago
can u.s spy agencies stop white terror
other countries have domestic spy agency
agencies to fight extremists at home
does america need one too no
no we already have many we have the nsa
spying on everybody as it is
and we have constitutional rights boy
would they love
to destroy that constitution i'm sure
each and every one of these people
crosses their fingers when they hold up
their hand and then swear enough to
uphold and defend the constitution
what we saw with the corporate alignment
from blm
antifa and the uniparty establishment
and those
people that call themselves resistance
who went to yale and work in walsh
just you know upper middle white class
they actually
are foot soldiers for a corporate
fascist state when the when the
government
and the corporations act in unison
to curl tale human rights and to silence
people
to to assassinate them effectively to
shun them to exile them to shut down
their
businesses when they work together
that's called fascism
right we are living in a corporate
fascist state
and the people who are the resistance
were actually the foot
soldiers of the corporate fascists you
know what i love about this left that
claims it's not really fascism it's not
nationalistic
was it nationalistic for germany to
invade poland or france
well you know it was to expand the
homeland right so when the us
has military bases all over the world
and now they are we are we have the
public and private
lucrative merger to oppress people and
seize their rights
you call that fascism do you think that
the qatar turkey pipeline in syria
to get nation uh natural gas into europe
is not about the us expanding its
footprint and its power
just like any of these other fascistic
states that were expanding and trying to
and to take land you have the us which
has continually tried to do that
and it's funny just i i just really
can't understand
how so many leftists fell for that for
that ploy look donald trump was not
perfect he was
particularly imperfect and all he really
was in my opinion was a disrupter
yes he held things back for a little bit
he slowed things down
there were some things that i liked he
did uh particularly in the past year of
of his presidency and some things i
really did not like that he was doing in
the first couple of years
but trying to get our troops out of the
middle east obviously all the things i
talked about critical race theory all
this stuff
was him holding it back but not being
able to stop it
and you had these leftists who claim to
oppose the establishment
licking the boots at first chance making
pictures of joe biden as jesus
have these people lost their minds did
they have them in the first place no the
democrats have always been
you know the establishment democrats the
traditional establishment left have
always been
loving the the establishment and the
federal agencies
and just fellating the news
organizations who have lied over and
over and over again about everything
notably the iraq war and then they'll
complain about it when it can get them
power
oh the war is bad vote for obama and
then as soon as obama gets in see you
later we're satisfied more war please
yeah and then we got what seven new wars
under obama yep and more worse coming
under the biden presidency but again
donald trump didn't do himself any
favors he was a reality tv star
uh i never put my full hope into him and
a lot of his supporters feel
absolutely screwed over and i think uh
rightfully so i think he was in it for
himself
a lot of people always accused me of
having trump derangement syndrome people
called me no better than cnn when i
criticized him
but i remember ever since i remember
making a video inside of
goa india i remember this perfectly
because i saw
donald trump sit down with henry
kissinger even before inauguration day
and he said how great of a statement how
great of a friend henry kissinger is and
i remember making a video saying hey
guys
even though donald trump is is promising
to bring the troops home even though
he's promising to
expose the federal reserve and talk
about how saudi arabia was involved in
911
watch out here because the apparatuses
of the state
are very powerful and they could
influence them in very negative ways and
what did we have
we had that exact epitome of of of
someone who
you know sadly i mean look at the way he
he he ended his presidency
i'm gonna reveal the real conspiracy
here right now the truth
to all of you well donald trump was
clearly a part of the deep state
bitcoin is clearly the one world global
currency
how could the government curtail a
growing force
of this conspiratorial and cap
libertarian
even even even libertarian left who
oppose the government
who hate it and think it's the enemy how
do you solve this
and they noticed a particularly loud
voice
alex jones alex jones the guy leading
the charge constantly talking about all
the bad things the corporations and the
government was doing
and they figured it out they needed alex
jones to
prop them up how do you convince the
conspiracy
right to actually support the deep state
donald trump
so donald trump goes on infowars and
alex endorses him and says he's the real
deal
and he trusts him and all that and then
trump gets in and he plays the role of
opposition
and then does very little and then
leaves without actually changing
anything well that's a
hold on because i'm not getting serious
i know i know that's a theory that
you're kind of throwing out there
i'm not intentionally throwing a theory
i'm being a bit facetious the point i'm
making is
you think about how these people like
alex jones actually endorse donald trump
and i i don't necessarily agree that
that donald trump was him for himself
i think trump lost and surrendered dave
chappelle uh
released the skit that i talked about in
in one of my videos today and he said
you know i really like how poor white
people said that donald trump is going
to fight for them in the white house
and he said those poor dumb people don't
understand
that he's not going to fight for them
he's fighting for me
and he was he was absolutely right dave
chappelle people and
that's what happened do you see uh dave
chappelle did that stand up special on
netflix
and then he did at the end of it after
the crisis like a q a and someone asked
him
what are you gonna do now that donald
you know what are you gonna do if donald
trump gets reelected
and dave goes probably a tax break
yeah well corporations did people got
their taxes back to normal
yeah no they came back to normal he gave
a tax break that that essentially came
back tonight
no no it expired yeah the moment he was
out of office exactly and of course
but to talk about your little theory
that you kind of speculated about a
little bit
the mainstream media and government were
losing a lot of legitimacy before donald
trump
wall street yeah so there's something to
think about sorry jack you you want to
say something
i'm all good i got to take a drink real
quick occupy um
so let's look everybody's having mixed
emotions on the right
right now it's conflicted you know
nobody wants to see joe biden and the
whole fricking
you know critical race left posse take
over the whole country and all the
institutions yet again
and it's easy to start pointing fingers
at trump and to blame
game and remember all the things that
were distasteful about him and made it
hard
to be a public supporter of his but i
just want to go back
2012 13 14.
that is when the intersectionality stuff
started to really take off that is when
the the rape hoax stuff really started
to take off that's when the uva rape
thing happened if you look at google
search also for like
intersectionality it's like 2011
straight up and racism straight up
around that time period
and things were just starting to
escalate and get out of control in the
war on men and the war on white guys and
all these horrible
well right after uh occupy wall street
just just interjecting here very quickly
you see how many times uh racism was was
used in the new york times right after
occupy wall street
around 2012 the term was the term
skyrocketed there there's a chart put
out
by uh i think is that goldberg's name it
is from lexisnexis showing all these
different terms whiteness
racism you know privilege all hockey
stick hockey sticks straight up
yeah and it's and it's we talk about the
comic when occupy wall street
you got libertarians you know luke as
like a ron paul libertarian sitting down
there with a bunch of i didn't even like
ron paul i hate all politicians but i
was akin to him because i
believed in some of those what i mean is
you were down there occupy wall street
and there was a bunch of like lefty
hippie guys
and they were like uh oh this is bad
there's actual people with pitchforks
you know
rising up introduce identity politics
yeah and then what happens is
the white people who are part of that
get shunned and insulted and get angry
and leave
and then many other people went vote for
donald trump no i mean
even i had nothing to do with occupy i
went down to occupy dc just to check it
out man that was quite a scene down
there i'll never forget the smells and
the
overflowing toilets oh my god it was
horrible down there mcpherson square i
used to work down there it was crazy
but just to get back people are
struggling we're struggling with
processing what happened and weighing
pros and cons and was it worth it did i
make the right decision
somebody like me i paid a pretty high
social uh and political and economic and
professional price
for being a public trump supporter and
you wonder was it worth it
and if we just go back to 2012 13 14
15 we start to remember that the war on
on men is starting to ramp up
and the rape culture stuff and the
intersectionality and the racism and the
anti-white and all this madness was
was just flowing and clock boy and ahmed
and all this crazy stuff was happening
and then it's like
well we can't have hillary cannot have
hillary
so if i go back to 2016 today i'm voting
for hillary again
there's no question about it and i'm
voting for trump over all 17 of the
other gop candidates who were
in the primaries of 2016. i have no
regrets
about that decision right right right
but i have i have extreme disappointment
with many of the things that have
happened in this administration but if
you're comparing anything to hillary
clinton that's an extremely low bar to
compare yourself to i know but that was
the choice
yeah so i i'll say this too there are a
lot of people that are all of a sudden
like
you know i won't support trump i voted
for trump into uh just a couple months
ago and i stand by my decision to do so
especially looking at joe biden now
signing he's going to sign the equity
he's bringing he's he's not just
reversing trump's critical race theory
executive order he's ramping it up
yeah 1776 commission gone the ban on crt
training's
gone but christopher ruffo a kick-ass
guy
from washington west coast he has put
together a legal coalition that is going
to fight crt and all of our institutions
he's really getting things done chris
uh i've had him on the show on my show
at jackie live on youtube a couple times
check it out i know the solution
what's that the patriot party the page
no i don't know if the patriot party is
a solution but a third party is the
solution
it is for for one simple reason we need
to
force the two parties to try and build a
coalition to win majorities
so right now the republicans are just if
if we win the majority we won and we can
do whatever we want
and then the the you know the democrats
say the exact same thing what if
neither had the majority without at
least let's say
trump comes out and says here's what i
want you to do go vote for this
candidate for this party and they
narrowly just win and they only get
maybe like
10 seats but the democrats republicans
are split fairly even
so whoever convinces the patriot party
to support them wins the majority and
gets that passed
that's what we need something like that
it's too bad it's not the libertarian
party but they're kind of wacky and the
guy pulled his clothes off or whatever
well there is an opportunity here
because the democrats are now looking
for
revenge the republicans are pretty much
yellow bellies and they're the democrats
ten years before
uh before before the democrats so there
is an opportunity to provide a service
that says hey
let's try to make people's lives better
something that of course
no one is really focusing on there's no
really big political party there's
really no big movement about
making lives for americans better no
one's talking about that so there is a
chance there is an opportunity
that i that i think could coalesce a lot
of people against a lot of the bull crap
happening right now by the establishment
i mean i know we're just brainstorming
here but if you're not affiliated with
the party that's in power and you don't
uh caucus with them you don't get
committee appointments etc so like this
idea of like a real viable third party
in our current system
i don't i don't know this can be
factions there can be like the tea
party-esque faction within republicans
there can be blue dog democrats there's
got to be something that works in
between yeah maybe blue dog democrats
they're mostly gone and i think people
like joe man i don't think joe manchin
get re-elected
no he's uh uh he's a democrat in west
virginia and i
really can't see west virginia
re-electing him at this point yeah but
we need something in between
and you know just like you know uh jeff
andrew switching parties
isn't a solution it was a huge victory
for the right and the left was you know
democrats were angry
but i i there's got to be you know what
i don't know i'll tell you i got no idea
i'll tell you one thing though
the republicans don't deserve your vote
the republicans don't nope
the democrats are going to keep pushing
and doing doing their their crazy thing
i think it was jessie kelly who tweeted
the left won the culture war because
they were the only one fighting it
yes and mitch mcconnell is just wagging
oh it's he's just the turtle
going like wow gotta go slow and then
does nothing
stops trump it for too long republicans
have been the party of well hold on
there mister
why don't you slow down and that's it
not actually fighting
for anything not actually standing on
saying here's what we want to do
when they put in all these judges in the
supreme court justices all they're
really saying is
slow down there mister they're not he's
not putting any trump didn't get any
judges who are like
i'm going to overhaul second amendment
rights and guarantee it for everybody
i'm gonna you know he it's not gonna
happen the people who came in are gonna
maintain the status quo
which slowly drifts left more and more
and more
and that's the future unless unless the
people who want to fight for certain
things
take their votes away from republicans
and create a real hurdle for them
a real hurdle for him i mean i see the
unity party
kanye west really wants to be president
he's super famous
someone like that that's what donald
trump was so
someone like kanye if trump got behind
kanye i'd vote for kanye at this point
yeah me too
you know why the dude is a rambling mess
you guys listen to the kanye and joe
but he's not if you really listen to him
it makes a lot of sense
maybe i listen i tried listening to the
joe rogan thing with kanye and i was
just like
what you must yeah i think we had enough
i think we had enough of reality tv
stars
uh i i my personal uh opinion but i
think maybe the bigger
kind of change could happen is is if
people just
you know hypothetically not saying this
is true or even advocating for this but
maybe if people just don't vote at all
or don't participate in the system
at all that could also be a decoupling
that could happen organically without
any violence without any
fighting but what would the end result
really be um
people saying because i've talked about
it before too like a vote of no
confidence
that that was my you know i stopped
voting after obama and people would tell
me i had to vote i had to vote and i
said no
because when i vote i'm telling you that
i find your system to be
legitimate yeah in that this two-party
system of
you know turned sandwich in a giant
douche is acceptable to me it's not so
i'm not going to vote
or i'll vote for a third party or i'll
vote for myself yeah cause i'm the only
one i trust to get the job done so i'll
just write my name in and then i know i
just wanna
and just hope 75 other million people
didn't put your name in
no no just hope that for for some reason
i write my name and put it in and then
everyone forgets when the election day
is and the mail gets jammed up and
they're like we only got one vote
i said that 330 million people in 2016
kind of as a joke i was like
you know what i'm gonna write my own
name in and other bunch of people wrote
my name in and the next thing i knew i
was city comptroller
i'm like what's going on so like you
really could do something look i think
the problem is the question
why are we asking what the government
can do for us only thing i want from the
government is to stop
doing the things it's doing yeah just
stop
can we you know what maybe we need to
get a bill passed where you can vote no
one
like and if imagine this imagine you got
like congress right
and you you go you're looking at your
ballot it's like you know democrat
republican libertarian green party
no one should sit here in this seat i'd
vote for no one and then if no one gets
the majority of the votes
then there is no rep for that area it's
not like it's like a really easy quest
but a bunch of people are complaining
and arguing about how to get it done and
it's like dude make kanye president it's
the only way
well on on that tip so uh speaking of
bellagi and other folks and and
and the mayor of miami and people
talking about startup founders
they're saying the the first thing you
should do is build an audience
if you're going to start a business
start a company like in silicon valley
build an audience if you're the mayor of
miami build a social media presence if
you're a jurisdictional leader
build a social media presence so you can
use it as a way to recruit people
attract talent and get your agenda
accomplished i i
if this is the trend even for just
corporations and for
political leaders elected city officials
and mayors
the next president is going to come with
a huge social media following so that
that is where you have to start to look
like the next who's got the big social
who controls the social media
i wanna i gotta i wanna pull this story
up who will be our next president
it has not even been a day and the media
is
already salivating at the thought of joe
biden dying
well that's why that's why he was jesus
dead and ascent that's why he was
ascending they want him dead
ascending okay well hold on hold on
quartz routes writes the story
what happens if joe biden dies in office
seriously
guys it's not even been a day the dude
just got in
but we knew that was the game the whole
time they wanted kamala harris to be the
nominee
and tulsi gabbard dropped a gravity bomb
and wiped out her campaign so joe biden
was their only hope
and then they that that funny play where
all the democrats drop out and endorse
joe biden
that was the only choice that joe biden
was able to beat bernie sanders
and so as soon as it happens i i'm
willing to bet they wrote this story
before they were sitting on it they were
waiting here's it from quartz what
happens if joe biden dies
in office as of noon today jos joseph
robinette biden
jr is the 46th president of the us see
how it's written
as of noon today as if they wrote it
before he was president is robinette
actually bob is he joe bob biden
no better than that he's joe bob jr yeah
he's joe bob jr
i mean that actually kind of sounds
endearing so it does a little bit joe
bob
jr they say he is the oldest joe bobs so
so here's what's funny at the
inauguration
joe biden was older than all of the
former presidents who were there
watching this not combined no no no but
like you had obama bush
and clinton and joe biden's older than
all of them whoa
i'm i'm pretty sure he's older than bill
clinton right yeah he is that's crazy
yeah
he's older and bill clinton was like
falling asleep did you see that
bill clinton fell asleep and he's like
well they say it was the greatest
inauguration speech ever given
well bill clinton fell asleep so i guess
he's a old guy anyway they say
he's the oldest president to serve the
country at 78. he's even older
than the older the older president to
leave office ronald reagan
who was still 77 for a few days and
reagan lost his mind
he thought that's that that movie what
was it well that movie was real
you know we've talked about that where
the the computer because it's going to
fire the war games
[Laughter]
anyway why do they have to write an
article about it we know what the answer
to the question is
well here's what they say he's they say
78 and that is almost
two years older than the current life
expectancy of a u.s born male
which is 76.3 and declining the lowest
of all wealthy countries and 14 years
older than the male life expectancy of
an american born in 1942
his life expectancy is 14 years above
people born in the same year as him he's
probably already dead
well so you know what's really funny uh
because i said this as a joke
they locked down all of dc yeah because
the inauguration actually happened weeks
ago
it was recorded and they can't let
anyone see i'm kidding by the way well
he's been in political office for 44
years
seven uh 47 or 47 47.
well again almost 50 years now and and i
see a lot of people tweeting
he's going to fix things he's going to
change things that i'm like
huh when when joe biden first got
elected there were people serving in the
senate who were born in the 1800s
i i don't know if that fact checked me
because i saw that on twitter from a
journalist they said
yeah that makes sense they were talking
about how joe biden was like one he was
one of the youngest or the youngest at
the time
center to get elected 47 years ago and
there were people who had been born in
the late 1800s who are still serving
isn't that crazy and they gave him the
nuclear football today
yeah another sensationalistic garbage
story that we saw in the mainstream
media was
donald trump stealing the nuclear
football and other left-wing twitter
personalities
but real real actual trump derangement
syndrome talking about i think he's
going to set off some nukes before he
goes
literally that's the hyperbolic
fear-mongering paranoia disinformation
nonsense that was out there today the
sun published that
trump had taken the nuclear football
with him to florida
and so i tweeted out the story like wow
and then i saw the video of the football
being delivered by and i was like oh
come on you guys
well let me read some of this they say
this uh it's happened before a seamless
transition of power in the case of
unexpected events is a hallmark of a
functioning democracy
biden is healthy and vaccinated but
given his age it's responsible to ask
what happens if he gets ill while in
office or worse dies
after all that has happened to a
remarkable 17 percent of u.s presidents
8 out of 46. in 1941 william william
henry harrison
died of typhoid at 68. in 1850 zachary
taylor
died at 66 possibly of cholera in 1865
abraham lincoln was assassinated by john
john wilkes booth james garfield
was also assassinated in 1881 at the age
of 48 by charles
gutteau a lawyer who believed he
deserved a reward for helping the
president's election
interesting william mckinley who died at
58 1901 also assassinated
by anarchist leon charles gauze
i didn't know that i don't know we had
that many assassinations yeah that's
crazy
warren uh let's see uh warren harding
died of a heart attack in 1923
and was not as it was rumored at the
time poisoned by his wife florence
franklin delano roosevelt died at six uh
at the age of 63
poor health and john f kennedy he got
his head blown off
who's next the 25th amendment of the
constitution which deals with
presidential vacancy disability or
inability is clear on what happens if
the president dies
resigns or is removed removed or is
removed
ah yes this one this this one
do they go on to mention the uh the
commission
the line of succession uh established in
the 1947 presidential succession act
starts with speaker of the house nancy
pelosi
okay they're saying what happens if both
the president and vice president are
unable to serve
so it goes nancy pelosi and then it goes
chuck grassley
and then it goes then after chuck
grassley the president pro tempe
it will be democratic senator pat leahy
vermont oh no no i'm sorry no he would
be pro tempe
and the then cabinet member starting
with secretary of state
however the presidential succession act
says officials beyond the vice president
in line of succession would only be
acting as president
not become president after resigning
from their office
they will only hold the office until a
new president can be chosen
blah blah blah we get the point the
media is going to start ramping up this
kind of radic because it's responsible
to ask
joe biden's 14 years older than his
life expectancy for his generation so
yeah president kamala who did you pick
his vp if that's the case
hillary good lord and then and then and
then kamala
has a unfortunate accident
and then hillary becomes president and
the circle is complete
yes you know i have a tweet in 2018
that's just sitting there waiting to get
brought up
it's it's kamala harris will never be
president mark it down
and uh it's becoming even uh it's
becoming clear that that that's
at risk it's good that you embrace it
though i'm embracing
don't run from it i'm not running from
the tweet but man kamala harris
presidency
sounds terrifying to me effectively what
do we have now anyway i mean it's going
to all the same policies all the same
procedures all the same appointees
all the same crap i said i thought
kamala harris was going to be president
at one point
and then tulsi gabbard you know nuked
her campaign and so maybe that will end
up coming true to a certain degree
i will take credit for my a completely
accurate prediction which
no one saw coming that joe biden would
be inaugurated without a hitch
and it was crazy because so many people
were like i don't know man
i'm hearing this stuff and i'm like dude
i said 99.999
percent chance joe biden is going to get
inaugurated after the election there was
like a
i gave it like a three to five percent
chance trump pulled something off
because the lawsuits didn't happen yet
and then after the lawsuits failed i was
like it's gonna it's gonna be joe biden
it's it's trump against the
establishment the cronies he's got no
allies
he's got his supporters that's great
it's a lot of people and that's about it
the republicans don't like him they want
him gone and that's why i think they
might actually convict him
in the senate they might they might say
well interaction is a very serious thing
and this country must get back on track
in order to unify we're going to vote
with our democratic counterparts
and that's it trump can't run again in
2024
convicted of inciting insurrection i
keep hearing that the republican party
is trying to scrub
trump and all the signs of trump out of
the party do you guys think that's what
they're doing
do you think it's a good idea of course
they will yeah yeah but you know you
know what i love the most
joe biden is going to be inheriting
quite a budget crunch from president
trump yeah that's what
lisa simpson said in the simpsons
episode where she becomes president
we've inherited quite a budget crunch
from president trump
and then trump got elected and the
deficit increased
and the debt increased and now there's
biden but it's okay
because the budget crunch is meaningless
when money printer go bur
it just means that you the american
citizen will see your buying power
diminish
i hope you've been paying attention to
your ability to buy uh foreign goods
so you know what people don't seem to
understand about the minimum wage
and economics is that trade within your
you know trading
block your country or whatever can be
fairly static because
if you're going to trade with someone
next door like let's say your neighbor's
got you know eggs they got much fresh
eggs
and then you're like i've got some
freshly chopped wood you're gonna there
you have a kind of understanding on how
much work you would be willing to do
when we see inflation in this country
it's going to change the way we
import goods from other countries
because that's where the the change is
gonna
is gonna really really impact you which
is why computer components
have been skyrocketing in cost so i've
been we've been trying to do a bunch of
it stuff
and we've been getting hit with you know
certain computer components i think
motherboards
may have gone way up you want to build a
computer it's getting harder you want to
buy a tablet the price is already up 30
40 percent
that's happening right now not to
mention wow dude is property
skyrocketing
we are on track to be like ukraine where
a ton of ultra wealthy corporations and
individuals will hold the majority of
the wealth
and regular people will be desperate and
unable to pay their bills
what's really amazing so and we're back
for whatever that was weird so anyway
long story short when you have a country
that functions very much like silicon
valley the ultra wealthy are rich will
always be rich and they control the flow
of money
the poor people will never never make
enough enough to buy property ever again
and that will maintain the oligarchy and
that's where we're going to right now
the mass printing of money will make it
so that regular people will never own
anything and doesn't that sound familiar
in the future by 2030 you'll own nothing
and you'll be happy
yeah you'll love it i mean we clearly
live in an oligarchy today a uniparty
the corporations are oligopoly
oligopolists they're they're working in
there it's a cabal
at this point basically right well let's
not be negative nancy's let's let's i
think we should take some time
and appreciate the good things that
biden and harris are really great at i
would like to start off and say that
they're really good at
jailing people for victimless crimes and
they're very effective you gotta jail
someone
yeah yeah and and it's going to be
pretty boring soon coming up as well
luke luke yes listen let's go at least
we've got that going for us let's be
honest here
these poor private prison companies
their bottom line is at risk
look if people aren't being incarcerated
then how will they maintain corporate
profits
yeah what else is the
military-industrial complex supposed to
do hey look man look there are a lot of
kids running around over that middle
east yes
someone's got to blow them up fire up
the drones
like morbid humor my gosh
you know anything you're looking forward
to ian just like
support the guy and let's evolve our
economy
support stuff we're just talking about
him
incarcerating innocent people and
blowing up kids that's great for the
economy
we live in the empire i mean it's a it's
a masochistic
lifestyle that we have but it can be
better
we do live in the empire and i was
thinking back about uh your comment
earlier about what would like
empire propaganda look like in the star
wars universe
not exactly but that was one thing i
liked about solo was that it did sort of
give you
a taste of what like the bureaucracy was
like within the empire when he was like
trying to get signed up and trying to
enlist and it just you know it gave you
that sense of like
what was it like dealing with like the
line workers well imagine empire
if uh i was thinking about it because we
were watching star wars and it's like
darth vader is a quadruple amputee war
hero
who was horribly burned fighting to end
the galactic civil war
they won the civil war like if you
follow the whole history
anakin skywalker killed the the leaders
of the separatist movement
ending the war and was brutally maimed
and scarred over it
to the empire to those who supported it
he's like the hero of heroes you know
what i mean
he's like john mccain you know what i
mean so of course you got the rebels who
don't like him
but i think i don't i don't know if
that's disrespectful to john mccain
but uh there's there's an analogy there
you know what i mean
fought in vietnam you know it's messed
up what happened to the guy
you know with all due respect but hey
cryptocurrencies are going to go up
alternatives to the dollar as well
that's something i'm trying to be
positive here
i'll tell you i'll tell you this the
truth is as much as there is an
oppressive
ruling class there is still a
possibility for
those of good willpower and of strong
mind and body
to break through and and and and move
and find that upward mobility it's
getting harder and harder to do
and when it eventually becomes
impossible and they've solidified their
oligopoly where there's two classes and
you can never bridge them a cast system
essentially
that's when you get true revolution
because then you're going to get really
really smart people
who are capable who say i know for a
fact the bridge cannot be meant
cannot be created therefore i'm going to
rally
you know the people around me right now
what happens is you've got
people who can actually make their way
into the upper class into the ruling
class and become rich
so why would they ever i think i think
one of the harbingers of
civil war and and major conflict like
that is intra
elite competition it is it is the
competition between the
nine percent and two percent versus the
one percent
uh those people who can see it but they
can't reach it they're kept
out but they have capabilities and they
have means
it's it's the one percent trying to get
to the point one percent yeah
and so one of the issues here is that
our top tax bracket the progressive
system is like what it's a it's up to
two
everything after 250. so i think it's
something like that
what ends up happening is a dude who
makes half a million dollars
rich dude he can buy a lot comfortable
got a nice savings got a bunch of stocks
and he's doing really well for himself
net worth with a salary that high could
even be upwards of a few million dollars
him and his his family and his kids but
how does he get to the point where he's
worth 100 million
200 300 or a billionaire the problem is
if you're getting taxed at half your
money and you're making 500 you've got
250 disposable
if you're making 10 million and they're
taxing you at half you've got 5 million
so you have a lot more money to play
with to expand and grow rapidly
so if the tax bracket stops at 250
then it's really really hard for people
just above it to actually become ultra
wealthy
but for those born into wealth granted
wealth or who eventually get there
themselves
they can sustain that very very easily
that's the irony of the progressive tax
system that it actually enforces
economic castes yep yeah well so the
solution is either
i don't i don't believe the solution is
a flat tax uh the solution would
probably then have to be
more progressive brackets the problem
with the flat tax is that you still have
basically the same thing
it is it is for for somebody who makes
100k a year
paying even 25 they don't have the
disposable income to invest and to grow
and to experiment
and to play around with and somebody
who's ultra wealthy just more power
you know power tracks power the more you
have the the easier it is to gain more
and more and more
the problem is punitive taxing is just
giving the government money to
waste and burn and that's not helping
anybody either so i don't know how to
actually solve that problem yeah i was
going to bring up that point i'm like
when we're taxing people and the
government's getting more money what are
they spending that money on
they're giving it to their friends and
you know right right so the issue is
taxation just
empowers the corrupt government and
without taxation
this is why i think if you'd make a
choice between
laissez-faire capitalism and socialism
laissez-faire is the best
because at least power is decentralized
for a short period of time eventually it
starts to coalesce around corporations
and you get what we're seeing kind of
today
but if you go for communism then you're
just instantly centralizing all power
around the committee
here's something that's interesting
that's coming up i was talking to john
robb a fantastic analyst who's been
really on top of what's been going on
last number of years while going back to
the iraq wars actually
and he and i were talking and he had an
epiphany he realized that
socialism is coming but it's coming
through he called it personal
socialism enforced through the
corporations
right the corporations are going to
enforce the social
stand aside for people of color
relinquish your
positions of power this is the end goal
of crt it's being adopted everywhere
it's being beaten into our kids
it's in the corporations now and now
these ideas stand aside
give away step back lose your power on
purpose
give up to the to the collective it's
like corporate
enforced personal socialism
communism which is a very insidious way
of it actually coming into your society
it's like it's it's like
it found a different vector it tried to
go through the government it was like oh
can't go that way oh now we'll go
through the corporations
and now it's gonna work there's two
kinds of people
several years ago i had a conversation
with very prominent leftists
uh a writer who's still particularly
prominent today and we both kind of
concluded
the same philosophical assessment on
life that
purpose is what you decide decided to be
that there's no uh you know
like what is the universe it was it was
i'll put this way it was a rather
nihilistic
end result of our conversation that if
there is nothing to do what do you what
are we here for what happens when we die
we can't prove anything
you know so we're just here then what do
you do and what's the point
and i said then do your best to be
positive
to build to create to help others and
just make it enjoyable
for the time being and her response was
burn it all down because it's
fun and it's funny and this is a very
prominent leftist
and it was during occupy wall street and
i was just like why cause suffering and
pain
she was like there's no point anyway
maybe these people should finally
realize
that there's no point and it's fun to
kind of shake things up and watch it
burn
and i was like i don't think suffering
is is fun at all i think we want to help
and build things up
and so it's the light and the dark of
what's happening what i see from that is
when you get to the point where you have
this the insidious nature of critical
race theory
pushing some kind of you know this kind
of socialism into the system
you have many very smart people like
this individual i talked to totally
you know we agreed on many philosophical
points saying dude
i can be the elite sipping my wine in my
penthouse
laughing at all the stupid plebs who buy
the garbage we sold them
and i'll be rich forever and comfortable
and live a glorious life
if i just submit to the system and push
it deal and then you get people who go
the other way and say i'm going to make
sure people have the choice
and you know it's light side versus dark
side star wars reference again how about
that
oh they did write it that way well one
of the things you mentioned
that i think kind of hits the nail on
the head is how underhanded it is it's
all done in the name of equality
helping people but in reality what we're
seeing is just another transfer of power
to the super rich to the super wealthy
and to bring up your point
i do believe that there's a bigger kind
of cosmic energetic fight
you know a lot of people may look at you
crazy or side eyed when you talk about
these larger kind of
energetic forces out there but i
definitely do agree because
there's literal politicians in the woods
worshiping things like molech with their
secret society so
yeah i know you're looking at me
sideways but but when we have when we
have very powerful
institutions that that are circulated
within secret societies that are
circulated amongst some really political
dude
it's yeah it is political but i think
it's beyond that i think it's energetic
personally
and i think there's a lot more going on
outside of our realm of understanding
that that
that we can't even comprehend so it's
kind of like constantine the angels and
the demons are
looking you know kind of in between
reality coaxing people to do good or bad
and it's a
it's a bet that god has the devil to see
what will people when i was a kid some
kids would like pull
the legs off of spiders or take
magnifying glasses and
fry ants from with sunlight and kill
them and i went to a birthday party in
like fifth grade and all my friends were
there
and they took these wiffle ball bats
outside and there were lightning bugs
you know those
have you ever seen lightning bugs and
they were just smacking them and
killing them just just destroying life
for fun and i wouldn't do it
i went inside and i sat alone and i was
treated like the outcast
i became the outcast i became the
psychopath because they were all
normalized
but they were the psychopaths killing
for fun
and that's in our children takers not
leavers
i don't know humans gorillas we're
killers dude we kill we kill to eat
that's how we live
yeah built into all of us but you know
you know we have to practice
they were killing to eat they were
killing for fun but you that kids play
as a way to learn how to be adults and
as a human animal
you have to kill things to eat sorry
vegans you have to kill things they're
killing plants vegans
yeah exactly and all the mice and the
bugs and everything that are byproduct
killed and that but like play is to
teach you how to be an adult
killing a lightning bug probably not the
best thing i'd imagine i prefer you know
capturing it or whatever but dude i've
smacked some lightning bugs i remember
seeing the yellow stuff all on my hands
killing thing is being part of him he's
a smack debug i looked at you sideways i
was like what are you doing that's twice
that stink bug landed on my mic
first time i went that way the second
time i went this way i didn't i didn't i
was more worried about the bug than me
didn't luke skywalker talk about
shooting womp rats or something yes he
did what
what is that he's killing small animals
that's a cycle was he eating him was he
hunting
for fun that's kind of weird in nature
we also see some cruelty
from animals that just torture and play
with their prey a lot of the times
name the animal cats i don't know name
another one um
the the whales the orca orca whales orca
whales
dolphins uh whales with the with the
white
no no no no no no no dolphins trip trip
balls all puffer fish
dolphins will drag humans underwater and
drown them for fun
they do terrible i don't know if that's
for fun dude well they don't seem to do
they say they don't eat them what's the
whales they say there's two there's two
species on this planet that kill for fun
humans and cats
cats will literally kill and then walk
away most other things kill for a reason
but cats will like torture the the small
animal because it amuses them
i don't know about anything else maybe
i'm wrong what's this the puffer fish
thing was because
they'll they'll chew on it for the
toxins and then get stoned and then spit
it out and then it's like all messed up
and then they'll
you know they're doing they're they're
doing sure drag humans
alligators will just i mean maybe
they're doing it to eat i think they're
not that i i mean i've seen dogs kill
squirrels and then just walk away from
i mean yeah it happens all over the
place yeah
i forgot but if we keep looking to
nature as a as a role model for us as
humans it's probably not the right path
we'd like to take a higher ideal and i
keep thinking about that kanye
conversation with joe rogan the only
thing that i took away from that kanye
conversation is when he said and i
thought it was very powerful he said
i don't fear anything because i have
replaced all of that with the fear of
god
yeah he lost his mom yeah and that
couldn't be hurt
and he locked his mom that struck me
that struck me it was a powerful
statement
it really was and and i've never been
religious i was bar mitzvahed as a kid i
was you know went to catholic mass i
just
you know mixed family none of it ever
stuck but i'll tell you in the last
three four five years i
am most open towards some sort of
spiritual awakening some sort of faith
something uh than i've ever been in my
life and and i can
see i can totally understand the case
i'm just kind of waiting for that
epiphany
you know i know a lot of very wealthy
and successful people who believe in
magic
i can understand why i've had success in
my life and it's come
in part from just closing my eyes and
dreaming about it
and then speaking it into existence and
then talking about it and then all of a
sudden the world changes around you
and you begin to see the opportunity to
make that story come true in your life
now they say it could be positive mental
attitude yeah you focus on doing what
you need to do you visual you visualize
what happens when you when you say i
want this
you're now focused on looking for the
things that will get you down that path
yes but i know a lot of people who are
wealthy and successful people who come
from humble beginnings
who genuinely believe that it's magic
because
i mean i got to be honest i know some
people and i'm like how did you
pull that off and they're just like i
willed it i believed it yeah i know a
lot of people believe that you know
crazy stuff like that
magnetic that's where the word magic
comes from that mag prefix and it's like
the sun is magnetic i mean we see that
in the solar flares
uh our bodies are have electromagnetic
you know toruses around them or our
neurons in our brain when we think are
creating magnetic
electric power waves and we're connected
or
it's a simulation and the person who is
controlling the game is like
they want to be you know new career so
i'm going to go to new career mode i'm
going to go to pay for you know pay to
play
it's 10 bucks and i can activate
rockstar mode
dude i think it's legit a magnetic there
you go that's not sure like it's it's
we're experiencing simulatory we're
we're simulating you know we're reading
binary code like as senses but
it's a magnetic structure isn't it i
mean we're all experiencing limited
dimensions to how many dimensions are
out there
and other people call it you know
manifestation whatever you may you may
want to call it
but there is something to say about this
that has been looked into by science
that is
absolutely freaky uh and some people
call it religion and i think there's a
lot of power in religion and it
shouldn't be underplayed it shouldn't be
criticized
but for me it's something very personal
i experienced i had insane
if i tell you what i experienced you
guys won't believe me in so many
instances
and i don't even feel like sharing it
because i'm going to be looked at as a
crazy person but
i do truly believe that there is
something bigger some of power out there
i read i was written as one conspiracy
theory for him i don't think it's i
don't think conspiracy theory is the
right word for this what do you call it
like paranormal theory i guess
people were well i guess it's actually a
conspiracy theory i was reading this
thing online where they said that
every every person has the ability to
influence the universe
yes and so they put fluoride in the
water to dull people's brains so their
ability to influence is dramatically
weakened
and those who don't have the fluoride
floyd in their water brains are stronger
and that it created a dulling effect
because there are too many people i'm
not saying that's true i'm saying
there are people who believe that they
believe there's like a nefarious effort
by the government
to take away the masses ability to will
into existence their own universe
i don't i don't think that that far i
think that they're doing it because it's
good for your enamel
it remineralizes your teeth but and
they're just like damn the consequences
of what it does to your endurance
system yeah it's not good for your
endocrine system you don't want to drink
skin
because they just want it on people's
teeth it's like you can brush your teeth
but then they also saw that toothpaste
without floor didn't it yeah
it's so confusing i do one of each five
days with the without the floor and then
like one day a week
well we're on well water man there's no
fluoride out here yeah there's but it's
really good for your enamel
fluoride yeah fluorine is deadly unless
you're in a
unless you're a kid and you'll get
fluorosis it messes your teeth up real
bad calcium why is your pineal gland
legit dude there's something
does it really do that your pineal gland
you ever see that you ever see what was
that what was that movie from the 80s
where the dude turns the machine on and
then his pineal gland like turns into an
eye and then he becomes like some kind
of deranged monster
you ever see that one no what was that
movie called it's great i'm sure
somebody in the comments knows but
yeah so so a mad scientist creates this
thing to stimulate the pineal gland
allow allowing them to see into another
like
dimension and then the scientist gets
his head bitten off by a monster and
then fuses with it
it's a crazy movie that's cool yeah are
you saying that that the only way out of
this is through magic
no are you saying that one way out of
this is through i don't even know how we
got into this well you said that
religion people you know believe in
magic and i think that
coalesce corresponds with magnetic well
well listen listen listen
there are people i know who are not
religious and they call their experience
magic
and the people i know who are religious
call it god i call it magnetic
because i've studied physics i know
people yeah but but listen i know people
who say that they've actually spoken
with some kind of otherworldly being i
told the story before on the show about
a guy who said he felt a voice from
within his own body
talk to him and so there are people who
see that
and they go to religion it's really
interesting this dichotomy
it's people who believe there is
something else a greater power
giving them guidance and protection
whereas the people who believe in magic
think it's
their power well it's granting it's
probably like alpha waves and
the resonating frequency of the alpha
wave vibrating through your body so like
you're getting these
really long waves that are passing
through black holes and through our sun
and through the earth
and they're going through us and they're
causing a vibra you know the the
resonating frequencies like when a wheel
starts to spin it spins so fast that it
looks like it's spinning backwards yeah
that's the resonating behavior of
vibration i don't know what that has to
do with
so that you they actually start to hear
it because it's resonating in their
system
you're not going to be able to explain
magic to anybody because magic is not
explainable it's just magnetically so
think about it as messed up dude
magnetic is it is it is a is a
listen we have a general understanding
of
electromagnetism and when i'm talking
about someone saying i wish i had a
sandwich and then a guy walks in with
him there's nothing to do with magnetism
it's something entirely different well i
don't know if that's not something to do
with magnets
listen you have a thought and then it's
no it turns toward becoming real
you do this too much okay you barely do
this at all tim
bringing up something totally unrelated
you're the one that brought up magic
and and so so i brought up magnetics
which has nothing to do with it
it has the same prefix it's almost like
it reminds me of dictator
and diction
when when someone when someone says
they're hunting ghosts so they pull out
an emf reader it's meaningless they just
arbitrarily decided that something that
somehow has something to do with guys i
don't think there's much to that the
point i'm making is
it's really interesting that there's two
versions of something very similar
people who believe there is a higher
power than them providing guidance
and they believe in that power and
people who believe the power is actually
their own
and they're the ones influenced i think
that it's coming from there out there
but it's going into you and changing
your body
through vibration and so they hear it
they think they're hearing it but it's
just because they're vibrating like so
all i know is that if i have an idea
about something in the future and i
close my eyes and i think about it and i
meditate on it and it becomes a mantra
and it becomes my personal narrative
the story i tell myself and i tell other
people and it shapes the way that they
see me
shapes the way that i see reality then
reality changes
and it manifests into actual physical
real
things that affects other people and if
that's not magic
i i don't know what is and and i'm all
about it like it sounds fufu and
whatever it's a positive mental attitude
and visualization
and a person a crafted personal
narrative that you tell yourself
that you tell other people so it shapes
the way they see you it shapes the way
you interact with the world
we have there's so much data in the
world perception wise
that our job isn't to take in as much
data as we can
our job is to actually take in as little
data as we can
so we're constantly pushing data away
and not taking in when you start
focusing yourself
on on your goals and your dreams and
your visions the data that you had been
blocking out that was helpful
now comes in yeah one of my favorite
quotes in life
is you are the imagination of yourself
it's by bill hicks and i think that is
eternally true
and you should be really careful what
your thoughts what your energy and how
you spend your time
um and yeah that's just my two cents
here i think about that a lot on this
show cause sometimes i'll be sitting
here like oh god we're going into the
doom
cast because we're talking about how bad
things are gonna get and i
know that there's something to
manifesting especially when we have the
video internet
where we're like accentuating our
vibration on this we're imprinting it
and then it's imprinting on other people
and i just want to take the conversation
and
twist it and like you gotta take you
guys but
it's interrupt you know there's better i
don't think you know a podcast that
averages about
you know half a million to a million
just on its own
is going to be that impactful it's all
the different shows
all of them contributing and you know
truth be told this is a fairly
milk toast in terms of political opinion
we're not super far left or far right or
anything like that
we're not hardcore conspiracy theorists
or anything like that there are channels
that get
way more views ten times the views that
are staunch conservatives but
they're the ones shaping the way people
listen and views because i think people
that watch the show are really listening
to you as opposed to shows that are on
the background that are just like
washing
and those those are more these views
count
in a way that other viewers i'm going on
that's a bit egotistical
i mean i'm just being honest i'm not
doing it to rob anybody no listen i
think if we were actually
look there's a reason why you know i'm
trying to focus on building subscribers
and stuff because i can see the real
power wielded by
people who have the audience that
actually listens and i mean not respect
people listening
i'm saying i look at some of these
podcasts that get
millions of dollars per month and they
only get like 50 000 downloads per
episode
and i'm like wow because that's what it
truly means to listen to
that audience and so they're not reliant
they're not worried about censorship
i'm not gonna name these podcasts but
there are some leftist podcasts that
have called for violence
had have joked and laughed about calling
for violence and nothing bad ever
happened to them because they're not
that big but they're substantially more
influential and powerful than
than we could get close to being i think
you under underestimate the positive
influence that you have
no i i don't i'm just i'm just saying
that
they're the the the the true people who
are playing to the political factions
that are pushing either on the right or
the left are are way more powerful
oh yeah yeah this is many more of them
this is grassroots
we're talking to the people we're
talking to the people regular people
regular people this we're we're not
people people come to me on twitter and
like oh yeah why why'd you give up the
fight and i'm like
like what fight like i'm not an activist
i'm not a politician i don't work for
the government
i'm just like a dude talking to my other
dude friends and some of my moths out
there
and so like it's really just about
grassroots and it's really about talking
directly to the people and helping them
make a positive change in their lives
and one positive thing has definitely
come out of this is a number of guys
that i have been introduced to through
your show have joined the liminal order
our group
and we're talking about manifestation
we're talking about personal narrative
we're talking about accountability you
know doing things that improve yourself
your family your community and maybe
maybe your nation
yeah there's big strokes that need to be
done up here and huge strategies that
need to happen
but on a day-to-day basis to avoid the
doom casting and all that crap
you need to get with people that share
your values and you need to build a
community and you need to build yourself
so you can be strong for your family and
your community
and your friends and have accountability
and loyalty among each other and that is
something that has definitely come out
we've had
probably over 100 guys from the temple
audience uh join up in the limo order in
the last six or nine months and they're
changing their lives in a very very
positive way so
i don't diminish the power that you have
just it's directed at a different
audience
that's not that's not what i mean what i
mean is the people you know ian's
talking about we have to doom casting
and stuff
i'm like i don't i don't think the the
people listen to us
like i get a lot of messages from people
saying i love the show i love hearing
perspective but i disagree with you
i'm talking about how there's there's a
there's a mass of some of the biggest
like in terms of how much money they
make and how much influence they wield
yeah they're substantially smaller
podcasts in terms of audience size
but substantially larger in terms of the
impact they have on news media
and the narrative and critical race
theory and all that stuff and it's
because they're not scared of censorship
and because they have exorbitant amounts
of money
and they're connected to the mainstream
media who amplify their messages and put
it into the institutions in the
establishment yeah
yeah so they're just part of the machine
i don't
not necessarily all of them it's just
for whatever reason
they they they gain way more traction
i'm talking it's it's a weird phenomenon
but it's like they've gotten the ears of
the zealots and
the the narratives that really work like
how many how many cue
pop like you know shows and videos were
just driving the narrative non-stop
how many retweets was lynn wood getting
feeding people what they want to hear
and making money doing it there somebody
you know uh
a lot of people have been critical of
them to to to the very end they were
claiming
yesterday donald trump's gonna it's
gonna be tomorrow that's it now they're
saying
i kid you not no one ever said it was
supposed to happen they needed to wait
until joe biden was inaugurated
the real move comes in two days just you
wait because they still want to hold on
to that
but it's not even just about those those
independent podcasts it's about the
mainstream media doing the exact same
thing
we don't do that i lost a ton of
subscribers when i said joe biden
won people didn't want to hear it i
don't care he did
and it was it was obvious what was
coming yeah and there was a slim
slim possibility you know that was
diminishing all along the way of trump
pulling off some kind of hail mary but
there's a lot of people
who produce content and they get the
die-hard zealots to just pay up to it
it is a disadvantage that fair-minded
liberty-minded people
don't have the grifting works better
than being honest well or nuanced too
it might it might attract more people
but it doesn't necessarily work better
the people that are zealously agreeing
and nodding and scratching their own
back or
that's different than listening to views
that they don't agree with
but continuing to listen because i don't
know why because they believe in you
or right right right but listen we don't
have the the independence
we're we're we're beholden that's why
i'm trying to try to build the audience
and
build the backbone going to that we can
make
so we we we can do uh segments where we
like we were swearing like with the
first time we were like laughing and
just swearing as much as possible
because like now we can you know on the
on the on the tim cat on 10ps.com we do
the bonus segments
we can say things we can't say on
youtube and so i've seen podcasts on the
left literally tell people to organize
violence
still to this day they're making
millions of dollars millions
and that influences the zealots and they
buy it up and they never stop and
there's no accountability for them
when did you say we get to swear the
bonus segment will record
right after super chats let's do super
chat the bathroom and then uh yes
you could have just done that quietly
nobody would have known what
am i right he's also wearing his pajama
pants just fyi
what else you have not already smash
that like button smash it
jeffrey mccormick says finally going to
talk about aliens spin the gorilla
we didn't talk about aliens we didn't we
didn't it's just you know we get we get
wrapped up in the news and then it's
just like we got to keep going
but i do think as time goes on we're
probably going to i'm going to try and
incorporate more cultural stuff
especially into the show yeah yeah
everything
everything's going to be boring yeah we
did before
you drink before covid we had tons of
stuff talk about movies
we did movie reviews kobit's going to be
here and politics is going to be boring
i'll tell you what before two weeks from
now
i will watch people be for vendetta we
can talk about it
all right that's what we got that's
funny mute says hey tim after watching
will of the people and words in a book i
finally grabbed my
song books started recording my own
music and i'm and i'm starting to build
a home studio thanks for the inspiration
oh you betcha
no problem dude good for you sastryx
says scariest thing to me was the open
embrace for equity on day one
second scariest is the fact they
immediately lifted the ban on travel to
and from
terror hot spots this is not good please
cheer us up tim
well that was at eight so sorry i don't
think we delivered on that one yeah
maybe the the spirituality stuff was fun
doom casting
doom casting simple caleb says kate
brown governor of oregon
vowed revenge on our district state reps
in east oregon
due to climate bill walkout in 2019
we've been on lockdown like six months
despite being very low population
google kate brown revenge for context
yeah well there you go
danny miller says historic first day
ending xl pipeline that generated 2
800 jobs in canada and 10 400 in usa
including indigenous groups
canadian tariffs coming they're trying
to sue the us
oh for shutting it down yep that's funny
really funny
let's see crevels says read earlier
trump tried pardoning snowden but barr
blocked him
speaking of of being scared didn't
hitler use propaganda machine to come to
power
yeah any similar similarities to today
you know they say history doesn't repeat
itself it rhymes i don't like
too much there's certain things i have
no problem comparing to world war ii
in terms of like expansion war you know
weimar journey and things like that but
you got to be careful and stuff eric
bright says pose law any sufficiently
advanced troll is indistinguishable from
a genuine cook
daniel maxwell says if this scary
thought becomes reality we are screwed
in three months either biden or harris
will be out of office hillary will be
named as vice president and three months
after that she will be president
we did mention that i don't think so you
know i was talking i can't remember who
we were talking to
on the show they said everybody said bye
trump wasn't going to finish his first
term
biden and we're back
so it's funny we have uh we have gigabit
internet now it's remarkable
yeah but it's not stable it is like
throughout the day we have no problems
but something's happening right now so
it may be
uh it only went down for like 10 seconds
it might be our router box or something
we just got it set up like four days ago
or something let's go pull it out of the
box
put all the walls no you know you know
what it is we do have gigabit it's
insanely expensive
and it's because we're like one of the
first businesses to get internet out
here we're in the middle of nowhere and
so they just put the line
down they they literally just put it
down they the the node was built a
couple years ago
and then when i called them they said
okay six months later they laid the
fiber
you know down the road so it was really
really us who made it happen
so unreliable at least so far but at
least it's gigabit for now
so there have been a few drop-offs i
don't know why but at least the video
quality has been
perfect nuclear winter gamer says sorry
i'm late
had a you laugh you lose video and cute
kitten that really likes belly rubs vid
queued up before the stream
well that's definitely something you'll
need to watch right now yeah i feel like
a lot of people are zoned out today
definitely definitely like they just
tuned out like
i'm seeing a lot of comments from people
like nah i'm gonna go chill
good for real meditate sensory
deprivation man
that's cool stuff focus on yourself this
obsession with national politics is
unhealthy for most
everyone yeah local politics man
uh matt mitchell act says what's going
to happen as the economy fails is that
biden will just say that he inherited a
bad economy from trump
in the same way they said oh trump
inherited a good one from obama no
personal responsibility
that's exactly right they are the party
of no personal responsibility
eclecticism says hey guys my monitor
isn't working i have to print out chat
in order to read it
the paper and ink are really expensive
so please don't spam thank you
it is really fast the chat dude it's
insane jacob posada says at least i can
still criticize the president and not be
called racist
hey there you go good point mihail
kale says hi tim two days ago you asked
on twitter for advice about a 410
shotgun i'm paying to say that the
tourist judge is a goddamn meme gun
and not to buy it despite all the
suggestions anyone who says it's good
hasn't got one
well um i was specifically asking for a
410
3-inch chamber and so i think a lot of
people didn't realize that i guess a
three-inch chamber a three-inch 410
uh you know but uh some people gave me
some some recommendations
and there's some some cool stuff i'm
getting my makarov hand gun it's a
czechoslovakian gun
sweet yeah did you you know that story i
do not i accidentally ordered a ton of
soviet bullets
oh and soviet bullets don't work in you
know our guns
because the soviets didn't want the ammo
to be interchangeable if the if the
you know we came in and does war and
then we found their ammo depot or
whatever
so they do nine by eighteen we do what
what a standard nine millimeter luger
like nine by nineteen
um i don't know exactly i think it's
nine by nineteen right and the 380 is
like nine by
17 or something i don't know the
measurements yeah on top of my head but
all i know is the makarov stuff is 9x18
and it looks weird and it doesn't
work in your regular gun so somebody
sent me a recommendation for a
czechoslovakian
a check is czechoslovakian the wrong
term is it it is definitely the wrong
term
oh okay it's check right right yeah
check or slovak yeah
oh okay well it was from the soviet you
know era or whatever true so i'm getting
one of those that's gonna be fun
and uh cool so that's a box of nails
looking for a hammer huh
that's right yeah a lot of a lot of them
but you know what ammo is so hard to
come by these days yeah when the company
hit me up and they were like we realized
you probably bought the wrong emma i was
like you can't have it back
and they were like okay you can keep it
like they were saying we'll exchange it
for you it's like no
i don't care what it is i just sent you
guys shooting earlier and it was like oh
my god every
every shot is like two dollars yeah that
could all be going into crypto right now
it is it's crazy not the 22 though oh no
the 22 was was was fun but uh
we have this really crappy walmart
target that was getting hit and i wanted
it to explode and huge chunks were
getting ripped off of it and it was fun
shooting it with that slug was pretty
fun yeah luke fired a shotgun slug and
obliterated a portion crappy little
metal walmart target
it's okay though the 22 was fine it
spins around it's like wing-wing you
know
brian markin says hey tim you talked
about creating culture i started
contributing to it by starting an
atv utv channel with my friends with
hopes of opening own park
cutting trails on youtube cool
definitely that's what we need right now
there's too much you know you know the
problem with the right often is
is there's a reason why it's called
reactionary you know they see something
happen they complain about it like all
right this is bad i don't like this
or you know here's why we should be
opposed to this the left does that too
but the left will you know you get aoc
playing
among us she's playing the video game
encouraging other people to play it
getting all the you know socialist
leftists to play video games and they're
laughing and they're joking
and they're building a culture around
the memes and stuff like that
while advocating for their politics on
the right they complain about it
yeah we were talking about going atving
soon what was the name of that company
let me look them up maybe we go we could
go for the wrench no no no the
the atv company guys oh i don't know
okay
i'll i'll double check for dude ranch is
cool though i'd like to go check that
place out yeah
let's see x runner says jimmy dore and
other leftists are already pissing on
the biden administration
it's the white college-educated middle
and upper class that is supporting biden
protected by licenses that are not
useful
outside of the u.s jimmy dore's always
right on the democrats because jimmy
dore is an actual
left populist with principles and
integrity and so there are things he
genuinely thinks will be good for
everybody that he wants
and he thinks the crony establishment is
full of it and lying
and he's 100 correct it's really funny
jimmy uh there was a there was a period
where my channel got labeled right wing
and jimmy's got labeled
left wing by this researcher and i then
showed him a screenshot of both our
channels
where they were nearly identical talking
about the same things in very
similar ways like nancy pelosi is
crooked for this or that reason and i'm
like
what's the difference i've actually
advocated for
the green new deal before the woke
version came out
like the idea of investing into new
renewable technologies and stuff i was
in favor of until i saw whatever those
they were producing i've advocated for a
public option
and i'm like aren't those left as well
how does that get labeled as right wing
and they're like
i don't know i'm like so what's the
difference it's your guests
now this is before i had any guests well
before that yeah yeah it was a long time
ago
and i'm like if i make a video saying
the democrats are corrupt and then a
leftist does
and we literally say the same things
you've got a perception and framing
problem
i think it's because the letters are
read on my videos if i made them blue
they'd be like he's clearly on the left
conor o'brien says tim for btc 51 attack
means you need to be operating 51
of the nodes recording the transactions
you don't need to own any of the
currency
right that's what i said you need 50 of
the notes and they could easily do that
so when luke mentioned that they sold
the currency off yeah they don't need it
they give me control of the nodes and i
care not who has the
the coins right
eddie schroeder says 100 support lil
wayne pardon
watch colleen noire's video on it direct
attack on the second amendment yeah
right so a lot of people were saying
that he because he's a felon and had a
gun they're going to try and arrest him
and lock him up
and that ain't right a lot of people
what what are your thoughts guys on uh
falun zoning guns
second amendment doesn't say if you're a
felon you can't own a gun it says
shall not be infringed actually no one
who is having a hard time right now
because
the riots and everything and
everything's going crazy hitting the fan
he's like
i can't own a gun i'm a felon i'm not
that person anymore i got my degree i
work
really hard now i have my own apartment
it doesn't matter because i'm a felon so
i'll never really be able to defend
myself i was like
shall not be infringed that's right yeah
ditto
well there you go the the council has
spoken
let's see breycock says did you see
where biden's handlers rush the press
out after he signs his first three
executive orders when they started
asking questions
no i didn't see that mr
steele yo block says day one biden
cancels keystone xl
i've never been so angry in my entire
life canada just got stabbed in the back
two thousand canadians just lost their
jobs today fork biden biden cannot be
trusted
wasn't that pipeline like breaking and
leaking oil
there i think there was one leak that's
horrendous oil so 1900s man
it's the one it's i believe it's the
second highest return on energy
investment that's why we use it
more than one leak you've only heard you
think there was one i all leak all the
time because they're human made
and human things are fallible and
everything breaks that'll both take
cares who cares
who cares breaks all the people that are
lost i'm just saying things break
everything breaks the freaking internet
just went down here well like
yeah deepwater horizon when that busted
that was pretty terrible that's a big
one
that was a that was remarkably bad it
was so deep they couldn't get to it
yeah that's nuts you just let it we got
uh viola saying
joe biden's inauguration video is so
unpopular that it's now unlisted on the
white house youtube account with over 13
000 dislikes
most popular president guys
judo eagle says poole murphy 2024.
yep i will be officially old enough as
of march of this year what am i chopped
liver
you can be you can be the press
secretary i want to be in charge of the
federal reserve
[Laughter]
no that's ian's job i'll take uh
uh i'll take dod if i ever if i ever
uh like if 2024 secretary of state hold
on hold on
if by some third twist of reality
i find myself like through a security
rube goldberg
type circuitous series of events i
become president
i'm going to nominate ron paul as
chairman of the federal reserve
yes because that would just be a whole
lot of hilarious
ian as vice president of the fed and i
will gladly take secretary of state
as of november 5th 2019 i've counted 29
times that the pipeline is leaked wow he
says
i reject your offer of the president of
the fed
that was a year and three months ago at
least like 26 times or something
dez says you all need more gun knowledge
paul harrell hickok 45 brandon herrera
colleen noir tfb tv james reeves all
great channels with good info
i watch a lot of hiccup 45 that's a
whole lot of fun yeah
do you think we could repeat i'm sorry
who who left that super chat
for the gun stuff yeah d dez hey dez
thanks man i want to talk about federal
reserve for a second though
do you guys think we could repeal it and
then just kind of use the us government
to control the monetary the printing
that's what was supposed to happen yeah
and then a bunch of rich people went on
jekyll island
was that i didn't know about this the
conspiracy theory that they purposefully
sang the titanic
so that all of the wealth would get left
behind that they could seize to use to
start the federal reserve
did you you never heard that one
somebody somebody mentioned that to me
recently i don't think it's true or
anything like that there's a lot of
different theories out there i remember
hearing something about it yeah
they all met on jekyll island and then
we're like how can we control the
american people and
have them realize it yeah even ron paul
was like we just need to audit the
federal reserve repealing it is too
extreme let's just audit them and they
were like no we're not let's look at the
balance books we can't even do that
so an audi would start with an audit if
it was corrupt then we would have
grounds for
feel or something yeah when we find out
but after the audit is done and we
confirm what we already know yeah
gareth green says jack jesus was no
longer dead when he ascended he
resurrected first
see i told you i have a lot to learn
there you go but i still think your
point made sense he was rising you know
he was rising he's floating in the sky
yes thank you for that correction and
peace be with you
toby may says if only trump had stuck it
to the establishment further
sure he'd get convicted by the senate
and he won't be able to run in 2024
but he would be a martyr and a king
maker without equal populism needs a new
leader now
yeah i mean he lost all of his popular
support and he's going to be impeached
anyway
i think that that first statement he was
impeached he was already impeached
he's going to be convicted anyway i lost
popular support
a lot of people wanted assange pardoned
a lot of people
disenfranchised and are extremely angry
at him i agree
i agree that there there are a lot of
people
i don't think that he's lost his popular
support there was just a pull out it's
51
approval ratings after the the party not
after not okay let's see
let's see after because i would i would
disagree with you i i would speculate
though that
uh that might be some sort of bias that
we have from dealing with people that
that were willing to make a shift and
we're willing to talk to deal with trump
who also think about journalism
i think if you pull the average american
voter
on julian assange they would draw a
stone cold blank for me
i didn't like him before but now i
actively dislike him i would i would
campaign to
make sure he doesn't get into office
again after the way he treated us
the last week trump you're talking yeah
i'm talking about the way his supporters
were
just uh totally disenfranchised the the
people i think there's a large base that
even if it wasn't for assange
they're like they're left holding you
know out of a family-friendly show
you know the reference i'm trying to
make here yes uh but but they're
friendly they're you know they're
screwed over and i believe his support
went down
dramatically not just because of assange
but a lot of other
november november 3rd onwards yeah
basically
yeah i i agree with that mostly
oh here's an interesting super chat
darts said tim same time you had a weird
outage i did as well i'm in alberta
oh what if it wasn't us what if there
was wasn't there recently like a major
outage that hit
i think like cbs went down yes there
were a bunch of news networks yeah
networks the scott says
in star trek deep space nine is a scene
where ducat tells wein
that the truest victory is making your
enemy admit they were wrong to oppose
you in the first place
and only destroy them if necessary
certainly sounds familiar
yeah that's right trump's surrender
is exactly what they wanted yeah they
wanted him to go out
in such a way that many of his
supporters would be left holding an
empty bag and be like
what yeah but it's it's and that's the
part where i feel
i know it's stupid to say that the
president betrayed me but this is the
part at which i feel and many people
feel betrayed
is that at the end he could have done
something
anything certain pardons certain
positions certain orders certain
attitude
just a the right disposition on the way
out the door
instead of this this really
disappointing sad spiral that's happened
in the last month
that that's where the betrayal comes in
where he just quit and rolled over and
just went away
and pardoned a bunch of people that
didn't deserve it and didn't pardon the
people that did
he doesn't want to give his luxury man
what's that he doesn't want to give up
his luxury
self-centered oh yeah he's too old he's
tall he's told all right we got a great
one here from
michelle therese not since caesar
caligula
tried to appoint his horse to the roman
senate has there been such an egregious
and unwarranted appointment of power
to any one person in the u.s kamala
would be worse
that's amazing yep raymond fields as my
doomed side is going bananas right now
i want this country and president to
succeed but trump was the only one
stopping the corrupt politicians we are
aft
he wasn't though he was a corrupt
politician i don't i don't agree
uh terrible i don't i don't but it's
it's friends rich
i'm i want to eat it's it's it's not the
same
it's not the same uh a rampaging ball
sure
you know i think there's issues with
with trump he did some things like when
he when he was advertising his golf
resort on the state department website
when he had the military staying at his
resort and his family all like part of
the
i don't care about it that's disgusting
that's called nepotism you don't have to
do that and and joe biden
most qualified people son on air force
disgusting nepotism no no bro absolutely
corrupt donald trump doing stupid things
as a bull rampaging through the ivy
tower i don't care about it making jared
kushner some like
elevated to some level of quality that
guy and jared kushner negotiated the
abraham accords and got a
serious peace in the middle east i can't
stand that guy joe biden
son sat on the board of he's also i'm
not defending joe biden you are
definitely trump's corrupt as hell man
why
because he put his family in office what
does that mean they don't they didn't
deserve it they were nobodies
his daughter she was nothing but yet she
had this extreme amount of power in our
government what position what did she
have
i don't know what i'm sorry and you
don't know
you don't oh no no no no no don't worry
don't make us
don't assert something i don't even
commit this crap to memory every
every day dude you don't even know what
she did i know that she was involved
it's just trump derangement syndrome no
it's not
just trump derangement you don't even
know what her job was do you know what
jared kushner's official uh
it was like some diplomat to the middle
east or something his daughter's husband
what what what was this job before trump
got into office
you're concerned about the fact that a
politician he's a real estate developer
and then he became our diplomat to the
middle east well his father had to be
pardoned
for uh some that that's why yes that's
how he got that's how trump probably got
him to work
same way he got betsy devos to work
promising that blackwater uh pardons
and did you notice that the minute that
they got pardoned she resigned like a
day later
that's why the pardons come so late in
the administration they're part of it
day one she wouldn't she would have been
gone yep it's all bargaining
so trump is a certain is a certain kind
of corrupt that i've explained this
before
in that his business dealings were very
self-centered
and there's nepotism and what trump was
doing in the government was
substantially different from the
traditional corruption we have from
these politicians a different country
and i preferred it substantially
i i preferred it way more than what we
get with you you want
his feces or his feces i don't want
either of them he made her
an adviser to the president he created a
role just for her
uh-huh it's disgusting well he hired
another family
he hired him he hired his daughter and
she didn't deserve the job
she failed miserably to represent women
they were like hey ivanka a weekend can
you
are you going to be a voice for women in
this country and she was like no
what you're not even complaining about
anything bro i'm complaining that he
made it she was advising her dad i'm
complaining about
his family in positions of power so what
they didn't deserve the job they weren't
qualified how do you know that you
didn't even know their job
because she didn't do anything has there
been any other appointee who negotiated
middle eastern peace deals
in the history did obama
his administration get his new piece in
the middle east or did he start new wars
you're complaining this has nothing to
do with obama you're talking about
trump's corruption
you're not what what corruption he hired
his family definitely a piece of
corruption
why why because they didn't deserve he
didn't hire qualified people
he made a position for his daughter and
his daughter's husband you're not mad
about anything
i think i'm mad that he's nepotistic and
you're you're telling me that i'm not
allowed to or i'm wrong to think that
he's corrupt because he
put his daughter in a special advisor
role it's a president
so what i'm not gonna what is that
anymore what
does that mean what's wrong with well
it's nepotistic starting
she didn't get the job for because of
her quality she got a job because she
was his daughter i don't know that
because he
trusted her because she was family it's
like crazy you trusted his daughter to
advise him
and he hired her yeah and if you can't
hire their family
so what you can if they're qualified you
should but if you're not qualified then
you shouldn't doesn't she own like a
multi-million dollar
brand and he wasn't qualified to be
president either but the people put him
there and gave him the discretion to
hire whomever he wanted so it's actually
all the like
you're talking about someone saying i
don't trust the corporate crony lobbyist
trump hired a bunch of morons we always
bring it up john bolton but hiring his
daughter because he trusts her makes
sense hiring goldman sachs lobbyists is
swamp corruption
trump is a different kind of of
corruption trump is a different kind of
bad
but you know what you're comparing
donald trump storming through the ivory
tower
with joe biden's 47. goldman sachs i've
never compared him to anybody
talking about his corrupt behavior his
lies what what do you lie about oh
let's see uh he he did drone strikes and
he made him secret
one of the most absolutely and horrific
things he could do to us
no other president he like expanded our
drone war and
gave power the generals to commit the
drone strikes
and no no i said you don't have to tell
people when you do it you mean barack
obama no ramp that up
uh trump did that trump like trump
didn't start the drone wars no he
expanded no he inherited those
and trump did a lot of things off and
trump is problematic
but i don't think you're actually
complaining about anything and i don't
think you actually know what you're
talking about i think
i'm getting dms from people all over the
place they're going nuts right now
well clearly you guys didn't take your
ashwagandha i took three
i think it's been building all episode
because it's just a hard one to listen
to it's a tough day
and i think you often complain about
trump complaining about him making his
kids
in this position of power we didn't vote
for his kids
that doesn't mean anything are there
other super chats
so so it's like i'm going to complain
about the fact the federal reserve
prints money and then we can't account
for it
i'm going to complain about the fact
that goldman sachs lobbyists praise the
conflict in the south pacific
and praise china i'm going to complain
about direct things you're like i don't
like his daughter
i'm com yeah jared kushner a real estate
developer
our advisor in the middle east because
he's his daughter's husband so what
so he wasn't qualified that's wrong
jack that's
indeed i believe he did is that historic
precedent that we've that's like really
changing the game in the middle east
indeed i would say it is but when we
look at the military-industrial complex
when we look at the banking institutions
they made money hand over fist with
trump okay
not much changed in that aspect so we
got to bring that up as well
the issue i have is comparing goldman
sachs lobbyists to trump hiring his
daughter
ivanka trump is nowhere near as awesome
extremely corrupt extremely corrupt
competition joe biden's extremely
corrupt too
joe trump's compared to ron nothing on
on
on joe biden trump's got private sector
bs and joe biden has manipulated and
exploited this country for decades
compared to trump built a bunch of
golden toilets
donald trump did a tv dude i agree with
you yeah sure donald trump's
bad mortal character he's he is
everything that's wrong with with
our culture and joe biden is everything
wrong with our government
and i do not like what joe biden
represents donald trump building a
golden toilet putting his name on a
building is meaningless to me
donald trump saying my daughter should
advise me i don't care joe biden's
saying i'm going to bring in a guy who's
going to praise china's militaristic
endeavors in taiwan
is horrifying donald trump being a
bumbling buffoon
is meaningless to me he's not a bumbling
buffoon dude yeah he did that stuff on
purpose
what stuff hiring his daughter yeah and
his daughter's husband
i will read some more super chats but
good chat uh
jelani williams says tim and co how much
you want to bet when the establishment
eps
i'm not gonna read i can't read that
okay who's getting epsteined
no no no no no no andrew lance says flat
tax defense
if everyone paid 10 income tax and there
was no deductions would you support
what if it resulted in more tax revenue
the irs is the kgp
i don't know about that last part uh i'm
not a fan of the flat tax
because uh people who have tons of money
can use that money
it's like i was saying uh if there was a
harvard study that found several years
ago it was almost like 10 years ago now
that you needed 77 000 for a standard
american middle class life
two weeks vacation new clothes going to
the dentist having health care
if that's all you make a year 77k you
can't invest in anything you can't
expand
let's say you make 150k you now have
an additional you know 80 or so or 70 73
or so thousand
where you can um invest in things and
start a business
and grow your wealth let's say you make
10 million dollars
you only need 77 000 to cover your basic
needs well now you've got nearly
10 million dollars still to buy property
to expand to make money
so a flat tax i don't agree with because
ten percent of a million dollars leaves
you with nine million dollars
you're still going to live comfortably
and have a disproportionate amount of
power to influence our political system
so when i see things like mackenzie
bezos taking you know two billion
dollars and putting it all into critical
race theory
i'm like wow that's really really bad
for our country and that's what's
happening when you have
unchecked wealth i don't support
progressive
distribution redistribution of wealth
and resources in this manner just fyi
you know what my favorite taxes
no tax thank you so how do you what do
you do when
you know you don't bankroll the federal
government to this large
centralized force previously before i
mean
before the income tax everything ran
normally through
local uh local taxes local jurisdictions
deciding how much they're going to spend
for the roads how much they're going to
tax
and so how do you stop mackenzie bezos
from spending two billion dollars in
critical race theory
who's why why should that even be a
thing
how can you com jack you're fighting
critical race theory
well yeah in mind you will you you have
nothing compared to mackenzie bezos i
know
i know but if i had that money and and
she did
she somehow earned it through her
marriage and agreement and contract with
jeff bezos
i mean dude it's hers
do you think it's it's right that our
government should be predominantly
controlled by those who have money
the more money you have the more say you
get and what our culture is dictated
i agree that it is uh disproportionate
that the power that the rich people have
to keep themselves rich and to keep the
poor people poor and i do understand
how you can see using progressive taxes
to redistribute wealth
but we just also talked about how
progressive tax keeps
people down yeah it keeps people down
well it establishes and maintains wealth
and caste systems economic assistance
the issue is the government gets the
money being the problem
yeah i don't like the idea that there
will come a point
where we will have an oligopoly where
you will have someone who is just so
wealthy
that they can snap their fingers you can
complain about the koch brothers you can
claim about complain about george soros
i think it's all bad
i think we've seen studies that show
popular opinion has zero impact
on legislation and it's actually wealth
and lobbying that has
the that that dictates whether bills get
passed sure so there's no
there's no government for by and of the
people anymore not for a long time
citibank put out a report i think was 10
years ago about the plutonomy
about how the united states is no longer
a democracy it's a plutonomy of the
wealthiest dictating what policies get
passed
definitely been like that for a while i
don't know what the solution is well i
think it's you got to get
i mean obvious what i think it is is
that you got to get representatives
out of office and allow the district to
represent itself
because individual representatives are
you can bribe them
but if you have a whole community of
people functioning as a yay or nay vote
together
you can't bribe the community or if you
did it really wouldn't you know you'd
notice it
and it would be take a lot of money and
maybe it would be
good for the community i'm gonna read
the super chat and i believe it i i
think it's a compliment
stan says ian is the tim cast irl
version of the fives juan williams i
like that i've heard that i think that's
i have you here but then it's usually
followed up with i can't stand juan
williams
he doesn't know what he's talking about
he's i've never i don't really know who
he is oh i think
uh i i don't like i i like juan williams
i disagree with him
and i'm really glad the five has him on
the show i don't even know what the five
is
it's uh uh five fox news house like
jesse waters juan williams greg gutfeld
and a couple other people he like
is the least educated and like speaks
with passion
is that what you think yeah that's the
vibe that i'm getting from when i see
that comment well i mean
no no no the juan williams is he like
follows mainstream media leftist
narratives
and jessie waters yeah yeah i bring the
leftist narrative to the show really
right i have to counter it otherwise we
just all agree all the time well that's
why you're here but
we can yell at each other lucy didn't
say he's the conservative chick on the
view
[Laughter]
all right let's see so there's a lot of
comments now about that discussion
gareth green says for advisors trust is
important as a qualification i say this
as a rich kid
the whole idea that we need the most
qualified officials is implicitly status
and authoritarian
well it's it's interesting um a lot of
people on the left were saying trump's
not qualified to be president
and then trump supporters said the only
qualifications are that you'd be born in
america and you're at least 35 years old
and that anybody can be president i say
the same thing about aoc people
mock her for being a bartender i'm like
that's cool it's like the coolest part
of her story is that she was a bartender
who got into congress and challenge
system the real issue is that
she's a careerist who's trying to build
followers but i like the bartender
portion
i love the idea that in america you can
be a bartender and go to congress and
give a middle you can be homeless
wasn't cory bush homeless i don't know i
can't become president
really yeah i wasn't born it's a shame i
don't like this born in the united
states
that's the only thing nativist
like this is the land of opportunity if
the person that's the
the most that cares the most that could
do the most good wasn't born here
so what why don't we still like empower
them to become president
they're all mad at you ian but that's
the whole point of having a country bro
bring it on give me a good white
criticism
i mean i'm getting texts and dms in
instagram
twitter text messages wickers all people
fix his mind yeah healthy and healthy
which says
ian what makes you qualified i didn't
say i was ian you aren't qualified to
call out trump on things well that i
disagree with
wow i thought you weren't brainwashed by
the left no it's not a political it's
not a partisan thing i just
i mean he i've been following trump for
a long time
since he said that obama wasn't born in
the united states that was he says
superman if it wasn't scared of green
rock says as someone who served in the
middle east ian jared kushner was
qualified enough to get the job done
more of my friends don't have to die so
even if you got the job through nepotism
he got it done
did you say that his dad got pardoned by
trump luke
yeah yeah that was recently though right
yeah that was recently yeah so what was
his dad's
thing something really crappy yeah
do you wanna jack yeah i mean i think i
have it uh
he like hired someone to seduce his
sister's husband or something and then
blackmailed
i think it's something really funny
stuff i don't remember that exactly it's
along those lines
we're hearing about it being like whoa
it wasn't jared it was his dad
yeah yeah um i just wanna i just wanna
make sure
um we didn't have a whoosh moment and
point out there are predator drones that
someone mentioned in super chat on the
cover of the jacobin magazine
and i wonder if this is entirely meant
to be tongue-in-cheek and mocking the
left possibly and not supporting it it
is jacobin
but i'm sorry it looks too much like
they're supporting it
you want to click it and zoom in no
there's predator drones up on top and
like you know
obama with angel wings or whatever
whatever
yeah it is possible it was just too it
was just too
pitch perfect now i think that's the
issue is that uh
we expect it too much from what the
media has been producing you know like
satirical news well you know
unless they really support the predator
drones which i kind of know i i've given
some props to jacob when they defended
free speech so
maybe maybe we just wished on that one
and they're all making fun of us now
look they're so dumb they believed it
was real
maybe but i think uh i think that what
is it uh poe's law is that what it was
yeah that you have to explain the satire
if it's not
you know explicit or you know that's
just on us then
i'll take it i'll take it i don't know
if that if that's true i'll give them
benefit of the doubt but i don't well
it's just
it plays into our worst expectations of
the left and it plays into
the highest and best slash worst
expectations people have on the left of
the left itself
so in that respect great art yeah yeah
yeah let's see uh wojciech asks tim
please give an answer on a yearly
membership i'd rather pay 300 up front
than 25 a month
i don't think we can do that i don't
know uh
if paypal has the functionality for
something like that
i don't know maybe it does we'll look
into it we'll we'll check it out because
that that's you know good on our end too
people like paying for a full year is
like way better than
crossing our fingers and hoping people
don't cancel but uh you can go to
timcast.com and become a member
check out our bonus segments which we
will probably have one tonight
gareth green says in a laissez-faire
economy the corporate influence on the
government would not exist
because the government would not have
the power to dispense favors
wanting the government to make people's
lives better is statism 101.
interesting all right we'll just do one
more here well there's a quick one
andrew smith says ian's the chaotic
neutral of irl
and sometimes i think i'm chaotic good
but lately i've been drawn towards uh
evil just because i have to listen to it
every day you want to watch the world
burn
no i don't want to i want to make the
world better i don't even think myself
is chaotic but i've become more chaotic
lately too
last last one last gal says ian your
comment about ivanka and kushner
terribly misguided
every president has advisors michelle
and hillary for example
the difference uh sex equals power
it's disturbing to me that people
wouldn't realize the danger of nepotism
that making your family in positions of
power because they're your family and
not because they're the best people
in the world to pick is it's been it
happened
in ancient times and it would destroy
kingdoms when you would make your
incompetent brother in charge
yeah but that's if like he appointed
jared kushner to the supreme court or
something
not asking him to advise him on matters
in the middle east i don't think it has
to be that
he put those people in massive positions
of power politically he did not put make
them secretary of state
or the head of this defense department
created a completely new
advisor advisor you think that's new it
was
not new he created a special position
for her
advisors uh bill clinton hired his wife
who had no experience at the time
to re to redo all your significant other
okay i get it what the they're part of
your company
yeah they call him the first lady okay
you lost it you lost your children you
had me there they better be
good about what they're doing what did
ivanka trump do before she became
adviser to the president nepotism is bad
unless it's your wife she even have a
germany yeah she runs massive
multinational brands and makes building
billions of billion dollars
she runs companies and now she's an
advisor to the president
makes sense real estate
to the middle east you guys got to see
that this is it's not
normal political no actually it's it's
perfectly normal that's what we're
trying to tell you no it's not to make
your children in positions of power
because of your children is not normal
no it is normal no we decided it's
called nepotism we just cited
number four in history what you don't
understand is that advising the
president is just who they trust
people hire advisors that we're like
hired an adviser what does she have
security clearance
i don't i don't know didn't jaron
kushner not get it he got stripped of it
in february
there's a difference between if he made
them secretary of state secretary of
defense
high-ranking cabinet positions so yes
jared kushner had security clearance
and he negotiated the abraham accords i
don't so it worked out right
negotiations saudi arabia imagine if you
want to create
a negotiation that would be weapons
deals yeah for saudi arabia and he gave
them a better deal
so he made sure and ivanka trump is the
one who cried
according to donald trump's son and got
donald trump to bomb syria
when donald trump attacked syria that's
according to donald trump's own son
so there is an argument to make here but
if we're going to criticize trump let's
talk about yemen
if we want to go there but i don't want
to start a whole conversation well but
there are some legitimate criticisms
we will we're gonna go nuts but oh my
goodness come on take your ashwagandha
we're wrapping up thanks for hanging out
everybody we'll save it for a bonus
segment where we're gonna go
screaming half of our lungs and swearing
and singing all the words we can't i'm
not i'm going meditating
hey i'm jack murphy hey would you do me
a favor guys help me get over 30
000 subs on youtube that's youtube.com
forward slash jack murphy live
also follow me on twitter at jack murphy
live website checkmurphylife.com
and if you like masculinity brotherhood
and sovereignty
and you're looking for a tribe come
check out the liminal order liminal
hyphen order dot com
if you want to get my special biden
harris inauguration t-shirt that has
them joining hands and
and jailing people for victimless crimes
you can get it
at thebestpoliticalshirts.com
thebestpoliticalshirts.com is the
website but most importantly
i run a youtube channel called we are
change the best thing you could do to
keep me invincible and keep me going is
to sign up on my email list
on we are change.org uh on the top right
hand corner really means a lot that you
guys do that because then
i'm invincible and can say and do
whatever i want without anyone standing
in the way of that so thank you guys for
doing that
indeed hey everyone i'm ian crossland
you can follow me online at ian
crossland thanks for putting up with
this intense
intensity tonight thank you
thank you don't break the mic thank you
tim thank you jack
you know i constantly am trying to
explain to people that i think that
the conflict here is a little bit of
cafe but after tonight i'm definitely
never saying that what's kayfabe kayfabe
it's like in wrestling where you have
like the heel in the face you've got
like the good guy and the bad guy and
they come up with storylines
to fight and did you draw no oh i used
to think it was kfape really
but now i know you know i'm coming at
you
[Laughter]
well don't forget you can follow at star
patch pajama pants in the corner
laughing at all this nonsense i cannot
wait for that bonus segment i'm
sour patch lids on twitter lyds and i am
real sour patch lids on gab you can
follow me there as well
we are going to shout your parlor
account
everything in the bonus segment if you
want to see it and it should be up later
tonight
trump did not bring peace in the middle
east okay we're gonna make that argument
go to timcast.com
become a member we've got a couple bonus
segments up uh uh
we're gonna put up more and we talked
about it quite a bit we do
the goal is if we if we can just break a
certain number of members
then we're basically invincible we could
be banned we could be purged and we can
never
and we can keep going and keep growing
once we get a certain number of members
we'll get to that point where no matter
what we get no matter what happens to
our social media accounts
we can grow the website hire more people
do more content and make our
own platform that's what i want to do i
don't want to worry about youtube
anymore i want to make it so that we can
be invincible so
bonus segment will be coming soon thank
you all so much for hanging out we'll be
live again tomorrow night at 8pm you can
follow me on twitter instagram mines at
tim cast my other youtube channels
youtube.comtimcast youtube.comcastnews
the next segment will be at timcast.com
for members only
and we will see you all then i'll see
you there bye guys
you